boop-boop-boop-boop the church or what's
happening now is brought to you by
nature box we all want to eat better but
when it comes to snack sometimes it
feels like the whole world and delicious
and it's all a billion calorie verses
boring and tasteless it doesn't have to
be that way up your snack game with
nature box and right now you'll save
even more nature box is often the Church
of what's happening now family three
three three free snacks with your first
order
when you go to naturebox.com/tyler you
again naturebox.com/tyler listen it's a
twenty six and a month and this ain't
dick it's gonna get more and more and
more humid and from work you're gonna
have to go out and meet friends and what
happens one night you go out you have a
drink but I be Pope and next to know you
getting fingered and it smells like a
billy goats [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't
have time to go home and take a shower
but you don't need a quick shower no
more you can take a Puerto Rican shower
you ready for this but days of back
[ __ ] portable bidets are back right
before the happy hour your zip home you
take a little poop tool or you wash your
muffler you scrub your monkey you give
it some air you put some hot water and
that mother [ __ ] BAM you show up at
the happy hour like [ __ ] spider-man
DC Leroux who's better than you you know
saying go - hello - she calm right now
flash Church and get 10% off your first
order again the bidets are back you
don't have to be a millionaire no more
portable bird days of back [ __ ] hello
- she calms last Joey Church / Church
oh [ __ ]
July 26 concept is a day the devil was
buried at sea and they took him to
[ __ ] now out of Russia
[Music]
Churchill what's happening now [ __ ]
here we go
Wednesday night Thursday morning it's
gonna be a good weekend
you
[ __ ] Korean [ __ ] beautiful sweet on
a debt as the cool and my main [ __ ]
death [ __ ] star either the king from
Israel Lisa I was happy thank you for
having thank you for [ __ ] being it
was a mystical what's going on Joey Cody
yeah I'm doing you [ __ ] hustlin yeah and
you know what else to come I gotta give
it to you
there's a certain reason why I put you
on the show and that certain reason is
every time I see you smiling every time
I see you not complaining you never call
me complaining about your [ __ ] career
and what's going on you take it easy
going and I got to tell you something
you got the right attitude that's why I
put you out because you just I
appreciate it I did your show with you
and at the ice house and your crowds are
[ __ ] crazy
fire fire fire every single person in
your audience they [ __ ] like love you
1,000% they are amazing they laugh and
there there's their I've never seen
anything like it you're following is
[ __ ] they they drink the kool-aid you
know you get what you give you know yeah
it's similar to your personality you get
what you give and in life and it took me
a long time to realize that and with the
podcast I always totally and all this
[ __ ] that's going on now you know I
right now we were discussing ticket
prices and I told you that I told these
people in the show that they're gonna
release another hundred seventy tickets
but what did they do they release them
to ticket merchants and on this the zone
for $70 if anybody knows anything about
me if you look at the Borgata card I had
the cheapest tickets on the board
why because I know you're blue-collar
and I know you need every [ __ ] book
it's bad enough they charge seven on top
of that just to get the ticket so it
comes out to $32 it's an embarrassment
but to me but folks walking to the
[ __ ] corporate world is nothing yeah
nope nobody knows so I read ticket
somebody gets seven [ __ ] dollars so I
want the people at home to understand
that the comedian the musician you know
a lot of these places man that's how
they they stay alive and they look at
every [ __ ] taking their $7 they don't
give a [ __ ] what you
and then if the people drink and the
people eat that's a profit also listen
I'm not putting down a club but I think
that we should all make something in the
evening range for doing our work you
know I don't like that there's other
clubs that have that surcharge that's
it's a they've complained about Segura's
tickets they complain about Birds
tickets but it's not us it's the venue
we don't know when we cut the deal we
find that afterward and that's why a
couple times you guys will see there how
cancel a room because they did something
fishy and I'm old school if you do so if
something sucks and there's a beginning
it's gonna suck all the way through and
if it sucks all the way through and you
let it do that you brought that upon
yourself so now I'm in business but I'm
not in business for me I'm in business
for myself my daughter my wife and Lea
you know we're business for us here so
when I look at things I go listen how
did you get adopted Lea if I got very
lucky you [ __ ] want I'll go back to
my old ways and start stealing and I'll
really rob you [ __ ] cuz I know
exactly how to [ __ ] do it but I don't
hire the green room yeah I give you the
respect that you deserve and I try to go
then give you you know I tweet I do all
that [ __ ] on my own you you only have
one radio station to promote me I do the
rest
listen this is what you're allowed to
make this is what I'm making
and this is what you're gonna make I
don't even know what you're doing in the
kitchen but I don't have those hundred
people on the Icehouse 62 of them were
stoned and stoned people or equivalent
of mozzarella sticks and Joey's
basically a nacho [ __ ] Salesman okay
that's what I am I'm like the Mexican
that got this [ __ ] fool card tipped
over I'm saying I'm just a [ __ ] nacho
Motilal stick salesman [ __ ] day if
they're good not these clubs they put
that cheese sauce on it that's like old
dead come just drop by I prefer the
cheese sauce I'd rather have that then
like shredded cheese melted oh I like to
know why this is what you you know grow
up on and you're used to that I do crave
like that disgusting like movie theater
not to everyone in a while but I prefer
good not yes you guys something what is
rap with theater popcorn why are people
so against I read like three things I
used to be grossed like when I worked
there was terrible why if I bring
popcorn from the house right and I get
Dena pop one is it double the calories
they will they probably won't
hey it's prompt with they have this
flavoring salt
it's like yellow it's not just salt it's
like it's probably butter flavoring in
it too and then and then they cook it
with like straight oil hot oil so it's
probably all of that and the microwave
maybe it's air pump
I don't know but yet it's and then it's
just gross like when I worked at a movie
theater when I first started working
there they would have it popped and then
they put it in these yellow trash bags
and they would just get stored for days
and then they have warmers in the back
you know when you see it all piled up
nice it's supposed to look nice but it
also warms up the popcorn so like we
couldn't like if we opened up right away
the popcorn had to be in there from the
beginning or the weekend was really
really cold yeah well not even the
weekend it was just it was - you guys
had a reserve of popcorn in the garbage
bag well yeah because they're not even a
reserve because they had a huge popper
upstairs they don't they don't do
anything anymore
that like you know that popper that's
always behind the concession stand it's
kind of a pain in the ass it doesn't pop
that much so like that's why they
wouldn't do it but yeah and then when I
look before I work there people told me
that butter thing used to be like rock
solid just a garden now it's just bags
of chemicals it's the same it comes the
same way that the soda comes my old
butter yeah so it's not like real butter
I don't I mean maybe some theaters have
real butter but most of the chains don't
I don't think that's [ __ ] I used to
work at a movie theater I loved it which
one in Chicago no North Avenue Cinemark
wasn't the chain yeah we would have
games like who can find the most used
candy in the theater when we're cleaning
the theaters as uh sure oh no never he
never found how long did you work there
like a year oh you never found oh that
was the best you find money oh
absolutely you find of condoms beers
people like you people used to party in
the movie I mean maybe they still do but
when I only I would find everything like
there's one woman took
and I just felt like in like the middle
of the lobby one time that was real
interesting people threw up when the
Blair Witch Project was playing I didn't
have to deal with that yeah I'd have to
clean up their puke is it true like why
is it and that look the women's
bathrooms are always worse than the guys
that's what I've heard the words we have
more openings so I think you guys would
be clean
well our openings are bigger than yours
not sure hopefully now are there any
independent wait beside laying low
because Len Lee is independent but not
really there's Chania a very
independently in Miami of any see the
houses left at [ __ ] you know $10
ticket yeah yeah like the last time I
went to a movie theater that was cool
was in Toronto this had to be 17 years
ago they had weights waiters already and
they had like a little table and they
didn't really complain if you took two
hits off a joint and turned it off you
know really yeah they didn't really
complain I think it was corporate it was
corporate cuz that all the chairs were
the same but the last time I went to
like a theater movie house was in 1985
and what to see the movie woodshed that
the masks oh yeah yeah the kid that had
the big head and [ __ ] and it was a great
movie I think she even gotten Academy
Award nomination she was [ __ ] good
shake it [ __ ] throw down dog don't
[ __ ] with her she could throw a gun she
hasn't been around for 80,000 [ __ ]
years because she's bad you know so I
went to this place in San Francisco and
it always [ __ ] stuck out in my mind I
forget what it was I was broke I was in
love even like when you're 20 [ __ ]
wanted to and you just don't love on a
Saturday afternoon
walked eight Ashbury and we saw this
movie theater was hot on we go what the
[ __ ] let's go in there and just watch a
movie that couches esta cool and you lay
down you could depending on home cut off
the the couches were four-man couches
but if it was just me and you and there
was 19 people in the joint
we could lay with feet two feet don't
watch the movie they also had things to
put your feet on they had a fresh
popcorn with fresh butter Wow you see
them open up the stick of butter and put
my machine and they had homemade cookies
chocolate chip oatmeal raisin cookies
and you could smell him a light would
turn red it was just tremendous and the
Tenderloin not the Tenderloin in
haight-ashbury night that's the you know
I saw the master in Toronto I forget
what time I saw but I'm really trying to
scrape my head to think of are there any
movie houses left around here like that
I mean there's a North Hollywood isn't
in Beverly which is good and then yeah
but only has a lot they have a silent
movie theater which I've been to once
and I saw that have you guys ever seen a
Rocky Horror Picture Show yeah terrible
I saw that there see it with people
throwing [ __ ] oh yeah who'd you go with
Paula like two years ago it was terrible
like this like I've never seen people so
excited like this one guy in front of us
had seen it I think 60 times because I
wonder like how many people have seen it
20 times like I could even believe but
anyways there's a lot of that in LA it's
very cool and I actually like cinema did
you work there when they had like
reclining seats now Dave reclining seats
now at the Cinemark up here where's the
Sun mark up here in North Hollywood one
oh that's I'm not good with somebody in
my why because I know exactly what it is
that's around the corner from the movie
to that say head you start bugs wrong
the car found it I'm saying it was a
hidden starbuck I'm downstairs
has anyone ever liked it have there been
any more accidents by your coffee shop
like we used to sit by at that coffee
shop and just watch this one
intersection and there'd be an accident
every 90 mm
you didn't call 3-1-1 on them it's dad
they [ __ ] screech tires there but I'm
happy there cuz there's a war for you to
[ __ ] hit me in that coffee shop you
gotta be coming with a [ __ ] Russian
tank because you got to go through a
wall and two cars but that's why I'm
comfortable there you sit inside
I sit outside I don't sit inside [ __ ]
people go crazy in coffee shops I need
to run when I sit down I listen for the
last two years when I sit down I already
got two outs I said close to my daughter
strike the [ __ ] grab her by the waist
and start running like a [ __ ]
my wife she's on her own every man for
himself you know what saying my wife is
on her own my wife needs to get shot in
the foot one time so she learns to pay
attention you don't say my wife is going
lows she's very sweet and she doesn't
know the ways of the world and she takes
her eye off the prize too much and it
drives me [ __ ] crazy I gotta say
something to every once in a while you
know and she takes her eyes off the
prize for too long and that's what
people always say I took my eyes off her
for two seconds listen don't take your
[ __ ] eyes off oh yeah I'll tell you a
story but I'm gonna look at you yeah you
want to come over and tell me talk to me
when I'm with my daughter you could talk
all the [ __ ] you want to you turn green
I don't give a [ __ ] if you [ __ ] got a
dildo up your ass or you jumping up and
down and I might not look at you I might
look over here we 10 seconds just to
make sure you're alright but I always
got mine the prize you know there's
people in life that never really watched
their surroundings there's a story of
this woman who left her daughter on top
of her car because she was high and
drove away with the [ __ ] car seat on
top of the car [ __ ] idea and it just
happened recently it's terrible that
something on then ended up passing away
but like are you here although like they
like in that they're playing in the
driveway sometimes and they just they're
too small and you're just not paying
attention as you come into the driveway
okay oh my god listen we tell you
something man
I used to be the king
that's how people run the podcast right
now I used to be the king of get the
[ __ ] blaze like I do now and getting
right in the [ __ ] car ten minutes
later and you know what it's cute man
sometimes you see [ __ ] sometimes you
giggle but sometimes just some close
calls yeah I leave snap disk why I have
all the cats I have is because there was
a cat [ __ ] foundation behind my house
at one time there was 37 kittens by
miles that's how many cats then that's
samurai was [ __ ] Wow at one time you
had her Jimmy's mother pregnant remember
Demi Ali and the girls coming from a
complete different [ __ ] woman he was
[ __ ] it listen he was filming he was
[ __ ] his kid he was [ __ ] mama
and then she would have a limit and by
the time there was seven months old he
was knocking him up already his own
daughters and if he would knock up three
of his daughters one would die and the
other two would have [ __ ] nine kids
and then he would knock those up then it
was a it was a time in the backyard
where he had four different colony of
cats that he was knocking up every cat
was Siamese beautiful he has beautiful
stock that cat was born to stuff his
balls when he used to walk was so
[ __ ] big and black even though he was
gold with a beautiful blue face and his
eyes were blue like those sparkling
label you see that [ __ ] label you've
never seen a cat's eyes like that let me
tell you something the nine years older
than that building he didn't take food
from me one time as hungry as he was he
was stoic he was tough picky he was
tough but he [ __ ] all those [ __ ]
cats back there
and the point is one day I went out
there [ __ ] with mall just it was even
[ __ ] all the dogs went along is
edible marijuana and all this reef fish
had started one day brought one home in
the afternoon got super [ __ ] high
super [ __ ] high and I walked
downstairs to run an errand I got my
little meal and I had a neon then that
was a piece of [ __ ] and I put that bug
and I looked around I looked around I
looked around I looked around [ __ ]
nothing I get in the car I start the car
I Drive it and I got a weird feeling
come on I ran over one of the [ __ ]
kids oh I'm gonna take it and bury it
you know it was horrible and that's one
of the reasons why I don't do it but it
would be you know what man even my
wife's I don't think he ran over I think
he was dead already
from what because all those cats that
time they would just die back there from
me me from one of the some Texas [ __ ]
would attack them and then you get an e
make your legs swell so my wife said I
don't think you killed him because his
legs were already swollen trust me I
used to make a lot of noise by those
cars I knew that kids were all in those
garages no yeah there were kittens in
all those 11 garages there was a garage
on the corner in a bar like a real gas
station garage and they they'd shut down
so the garage part stayed in there and
they had thousands of cats when they
knocked it down all those cats moved
into my yard this was 2000 I dealt with
this from 2000 to 2006 and then mama got
shipped off to Vegas she gave her last
she must had 19,000 kittens they really
hit all get a ship to the Vegas because
there was like a possum back there like
there was a [ __ ] possum that was
coming back there I was like mixed with
a pig
so mama went to get [ __ ] bird she
crossed the street when in the
neighbor's yard and the neighbor had
like a towel hanging mama took it down
put it in the corner and had no [ __ ]
kittens so that neighbor went to Vegas
and took mom and the
to Vegas with it okay that was the end
of that samurai they had to remove her
from samurai samurai the last time I saw
Samurai his face was hanging off and my
wife tried to give an antibiotic and he
hissed odda and my wife tried to sneak
antibiotics and his food and he won't
eat the [ __ ] food so I never saw a
samurai again how you think samurais
doing sick samurai is dead I haven't
seen them since 2006 and I left the
building in 2009 he would have found you
samurai five died of an infection
knowing samurai he probably like he was
so [ __ ] stoic and so to the tea
I guarantee committed harakiri he got a
piece of glass stuck on his stomach and
killed himself because he knew he was
dying from like a bad infection Harry
Caray I recarey
[ __ ] stoic dick damn if he was alive
he would have found you he would have
followed the skunk smell that cat didn't
like people even cats in his yard I was
in the bathroom one afternoon was the
sunny Anthony I would the window open
and I was in there doing something
popping a pimple brushing my teeth and I
heard a noise and I went to the window
and on the tree was Fidel's fini uh uh
super birds falling bigger than a
[ __ ] house on a tree gonna know who
the [ __ ] is he is for that up in the
[ __ ] trach and I looked down and this
the samurai you know two stories away a
garage away plus a [ __ ] 20-foot tree
away and he's mad doggin this [ __ ]
cat in the tree and this cat's going and
all since the samurai ghost okay
[ __ ] he ran to the edge of the
[ __ ] garage jumped on the dumpster
jumped on the garage ran to the [ __ ]
tree and the cats a big round by this
time he's
like those [ __ ] catch noises and
samurai climbing that tree like a
[ __ ] lion and climbed up that [ __ ]
tree and they started fighting the
[ __ ] tree
then they both went off the tree and
that was it I'm like whoa it all went
down like four [ __ ] minutes that's
how fast in the first noise I had were
they [ __ ] they were fighting they
were fighting to the death that night
nine o'clock ten o'clock I forgot all
about I'm outside waiting for the coke
dealer to make a delivery I'm outside
minding my own business I look over to
the left and there's Superbad father
walking like with a limp and [ __ ] his
[ __ ] neck hanging off he looks over
me like I was a tough [ __ ] afternoon
I'm sucking down my won-won or something
I saw him after than a few times it
sounds like a reality show why he was
tougher than that one night I look in
the backyard I'm I just saw a cat that
didn't belong there just a cat that
didn't drink at like a strake that
that's it Wow it smells like that back
in this be a great Kingdom back here and
all of a sudden I hear this [ __ ]
samurai runs up on them and this cat
starts running his [ __ ] I go okay that's
what happens listen I swear my mother I
get in my car
ten minutes later I'm gonna Tommy stuff
I get in my car and make a right I'm on
someone and I'm pointing to car towards
LaBrea
and I'm headed west and do you know what
I see
by Highland [ __ ] samurai chasing that
cat across Island at 9:45 at night
across Highland by Hollywood high school
right there crossing that Street that's
the type of caddy was he chased that
[ __ ] ten blocks down how many
blocks do you think he owned samurai
that whole neighborhood the post office
because he would come out of the post
office in three zip codes he lived he
lived in the post office he that was his
turf the post office and that [ __ ]
limite so yeah one of those big peel
boxes I sat out there with those cats
I got infatuated with them you get in
fact surely there was something like I
was like I didn't had cats neither and
they were I watch them i watch them
every night I would go home get like a
soda pee you know roll a joint I go in
the backyard and I just sit there and
watch and at that time there had to be
three different families of kids and
some of them would play with each other
some of them would just fight and
whatever samurai came around they all
ran into a corner because they were
truly scared of them
there was one morning I woke up and
there was dead kittens all over he had
killed all them because don't the faster
he killed the kittens and the mothers
stopped feeding them through their
breasts the faster you get back the
[ __ ] I didn't know that oh that's
what he would do he's like I'm in the
mood to he doesn't care that they're his
kids he didn't give a French response
Jesus it was the weirdest thing so all
right that's crazy how weird the body is
like if like if anime like a human
killed their kid to [ __ ] the wife the
wife wouldn't be like okay but it's just
biological if there's no kittens around
the females gonna like to be ready to
floods weird that's crazy it's a it was
a crazy thing and it was weird the
clicks that they had so I wrote
something I wrote it I talked to just be
a side girl and they won't like that he
had side girls he had 25 Jesus and if
they didn't want to be there were his
side girls didn't have a [ __ ] choice
the weirdest thing I have a cat named
Lulu and she's a beautiful [ __ ] cat
beautiful till today she's always been
loving yes they saw I rubbed her and she
turned and show me a stomach she doesn't
swipe in my hand I'm no Lulu so she was
broken and I love that particular
does Lulu play the piano no no Lulu is
just really cute and she has a sister
named Evie she has a brother named
Superbad and a brother that died named
DJ they used to live outside in the [ __ ]
so it's really weird one night I was out
there but 9:30 I was headed to the store
and Lulu was in my alleyway everybody
else
her other brothers and sisters were over
here in the backyard there was like a
tomato thing back there you know what
else lived in that backyard a [ __ ]
old Ternes do you do it by zoo like what
no no no there was a neighbor who moved
in the apartment building and had a
turtle like an exotic turtle he brought
from [ __ ] Argentina some [ __ ] and he
put it in the backyard he's still there
he lived there for 20-something years so
he would feed the turtle lettuce the
turtle would bury itself have to eat but
whenever the turtle came out he was just
[ __ ] big the guy died in this
apartment and some [ __ ] Zoo came and
got the turtle jesus [ __ ] think
you're dealing with joy bananas Lee they
got bumps them sitting over here [ __ ]
DMZ in it I'm dropping facts on you
[ __ ] see like I took a year for that
turtle to get into your yard I took I
don't know I never I never really messed
them like I could look to the shell they
said he was very old and stuff like that
I never really picked them up I'm not
good with turtles they make good use and
a half shell who's your favorite ninja
turtle I have no [ __ ] idea Donatello
what the [ __ ] you think it did least I
am what's going on in your world
[ __ ] I'm doing good I got I never
knew you went to that that [ __ ] rocky
herbaceous that's a new one you drove
home that was terrible wasn't it she
must have talked to you no I was I've
never been to the up it no you don't
move II I don't know I don't the theater
helps everything he humps everything you
know I know a restaurant here's a funny
thing he helps restaurants he goes
through like never again do you go no I
could make even Tim young and dumpling
Olympic you should go what do you I
don't know myung in dumpling meat listen
listen to me this kids like oh and 22
Bourdain went there will Cho goes
everywhere yeah boarding every whoever
gives him five g's and the free dinner
what day shows up nothing awfully yeah
what game with their master coogo yeah
that's the coin gonna go she's smarter
than that [ __ ] she knows you can't trust
those I like Koreans she goes down in
Miami [ __ ] what kind of what kind of
dumplings Chinese dumplings I'm think
Korean they have kimchi and stuff when
you bring it out they have all those the
kimchi in the does let's go there let's
go there
listen don't go there don't go anywhere
with you eat he's the kiss of death
I'll let you do some research and then
if you'd like to do how much research
can you possibly do a Korean barbecue
yes
that's I'm not a good cook so it always
scares me I don't want to have to be in
charge of the cooking oh then you just
go to one of the ones where they make it
in the bag what they make it for you
yeah it'd make the barbecue like don't
cook it yourself I don't want to cook it
myself I hate that yeah that's the whole
reason why I'm going out I didn't know
they even have that yeah yeah so that's
the way people has a barbecue thing oh
that's the one were you going and you
pick your own supplies and then you come
up with a [ __ ] thing and you movable
or some [ __ ] you have a grill at the
table but then you walk out of there
smelling like [ __ ] duck yeah that
okay that's completely different I don't
want I want them what's going on your
career circle um you know you my show
just came out which my sketch show okay
it's called sorry not sorry
just came out on go 90
just started airing Tuesday mm-hmm what
kind of last time I was here I was
working on it okay and I went to the
next day to work I was super blaze out
of my mind because you gave me that star
of death you ready for the start tonight
yeah let's do it
yeah that's really good a freshman
though well I I think I had a corner a
corner of a star last time I'm ready for
a half a star this time that's right how
many milligrams is this 120 this is the
weakness 120 is a lot some edibles they
only have like [ __ ] 10 milligrams
that's all you need right there that's
warning you this is 40 all right one
time you came in he ate those [ __ ]
edibles I didn't know little [ __ ] you
are you a cross-eyed and I was [ __ ] up
so we're looking at each other all
[ __ ] up can you fart in did I mmm-hmm
yeah I'm sorry
no I loved it I loved it very fun around
women farting has the opportunity to get
closer
well if you fought I don't want to get
close to you it's no disrespect wow what
kind of show is this sketch wise it's a
just like little sketches you know how
many minutes um it's like 20 20 minutes
each what a minute sketches no no no no
they're like a compilation of sketches
and who did sketch the sketches with you
Tracy stomp of men and matthews and
hannah pocus okay so you got a little
crew a little [ __ ] yes I'm that wide
yeah can you get how many episodes eight
episodes and then it'll get picked up
for a second season
well hopefully so go watch it and what
network is this go 90 and where is this
home it's on go 90 calm really mm-hmm
I'm worried [ __ ] Daly this is your
job you know it's for the kids it's for
the Millennials right now how old the
millennial
right now supposed to be there like what
20 to 35 or something it was only one
you'll probably they're like the biggest
each group that exists now that is the
craziest [ __ ] age group in the world
that's crazy
you know they're doing dumb [ __ ] what
kind of dumb [ __ ] you know
dumb [ __ ] with their phones everybody's
addicted they grow up on their phones
these kids well I saw I saw this stat on
Facebook so it could be totally fake but
it was something like the that age group
is the most educated but like the least
employed generation ever like that which
means what I think that they probably
more people have gone in college than
before I would guess but then it's also
like I was talking with someone
yesterday with Paula one of her friends
from law school just finished law school
decided oh I don't want to be a lawyer
now this is gonna take the bar but is
now signed up to go to seven years of
medical school so I know people like
that too I know people who have three or
four master's degree they're addicted to
school yeah it's cool you should just or
won't get a job they don't want to face
the [ __ ] work you should just get a
job as a counselor at your school if you
don't ever want to leave your college I
should be pissed the other side of that
coin like I've been like a kid when I
was growing up you had options Esther
Cole okay I bet you like joy what died
Bach it's okay the first option is you
go to college the second option is you
going to service the third option was
your father had a flower shop it may be
you wanting a large school designed
flowers but your mother is in a cabin
along Shore I should get you the trainee
program a lot of people had those
options no more there's not a lot of
apprenticeships left anymore in this
country there's not a lot of you know I
don't know about politics but I know
that they're cutting back on kid
programs so I can't imagine what they're
doing
the people just want to go to a trade
school that's the cool what if you just
you just want to go to a print class or
nursing school nursing school or web
design whatever I mean I don't know guys
that's the thing if I had a kid right
now the only thing I would have them do
unto be some sort of tech stuff like
when I was going to high school I had
the opportunity to go to a trade school
if I wanted to do what it was it was a
called Minuteman Tech I did some summer
school stuff there they have like the
plumbing and HVAC and they have they
have all that but it's a regular high
school but you get you have you have
that opportunity I'm pretty sure it's
still there and it's from a big area of
towns and those are like those jobs will
still be there to a degree but then
there's some like if you don't go to
college you're gonna have like it's
gonna be an issue because a lot of those
jobs are being automated what about like
an apprenticeship like construction look
up my construction unions
apprenticeships like if my kid was 18
he's just an outdated word are you
serious seems like it doesn't it I'm 50
something so it's not like I'm looking
every day for a fact an apprenticeship
no more trust me I might [ __ ] myself
from the age of 18 to 28 I was gonna be
a [ __ ] apprentice son these kids
they're book-smart but they're not
practical street smart
this way they're all unemployed but
they're all educated well um I don't
micro that guy who used to have the
dirty job show he has a thing like that
there should be more people because a
lot of these jobs are actually pretty
high paying and you just don't think
maybe you don't think about it it seems
but they California does have an
apprenticeship program let me say what I
did in 2000 2000 1982 I think my eyes
the blonde I had to quit you know I was
a sucker and whatever my mom died that's
why I should get a job you know so I
quit like an [ __ ] my son before my
senior year it was cool yeah I wasn't
cool I had a [ __ ] Hospital
you know I had to make ends meet I had
to pay rent and I didn't get social
security so I had a [ __ ] hustle you
know I had to steal a little bit some
little coke you know but that you know
you can't do that every [ __ ] week so
I went to Colorado and there was a
Colorado Mountain College and I just has
never had a little diploma just again at
the courses and one of the courses I
took was residential wiring you know I
took a history corners check because
everybody in Colorado is high as a
[ __ ] well no this is 1982 which
you're correct especially up there but
they didn't care I took courses there
and you know what I
I became an electrician the guy that
taught the class was a the city
inspector so I threw one of the classes
cuz he took you to a house and he had a
wire that was part of the assignment so
after the 12 weeks he goes hey man if
you're looking for a job let me get you
a job and he got me a job at Aspen
Electric at the time I was 19
I'm like always [ __ ] I got a job at
bucks an hour I'm a lot of money trust
me in New Jersey I couldn't do [ __ ] now
I'm an electrician and I would go there
every day and put my robe on I did it my
dinner for seven months and I really
liked it and for a guy who was doing
with seven months I was I was up to like
a guy who was doing it for two years I
was bending pipes I knew you know a lot
of different [ __ ]
the guy grow at the time I left Aspen
Electric but anytime
that that guy had to call to inspect
they would put me on that job because
they knew the guy would pass it because
it was his work I did the work how that
guy taught me to do his work that's why
they really liked when you took that
class but the point I'm trying to make
here is on my own before computers guys
I wanted the yellow pages and I made a
bunch of calls before computers trying
to find this [ __ ] Lee was hijacked you
had to go to a payphone with a roll of
quarters and you had to make some calls
yeah yeah it's so easy now it's so easy
and I had to make like [ __ ] twenty
calls and I finally got the hand of
Colorado State electricians
apprenticeship program there's a lot of
bad electricians out there you know
those houses where you turn off the
light and it turns on yeah what's up
with that who the [ __ ] knows somebody
put a bad wire you know it's like
there's only two ways the light switch
can go and there's so many places where
it's inverted I have been electrician in
30 years now so I feel about the old
water is the hot water it seems pretty
cool like a baby if it's something that
you'd be interested in
just like the California one you do five
years and you work eight thousand hours
and then while you're doing that you
also go to school three nights a week
800 hours is cool and you call on some
lonely housewife probably hasn't [ __ ]
her husband in two years and then you
[ __ ] walk in with your shiny is and
they give you insurance ensuring you
present your program the Health antenna
takes five years what's the requirements
you have to be 18 you have to be
physically able to perform you have to
be a high school graduate or have the
GED and then you have to have two
semesters of algebra with a minimum
grade of C and one semester of college
algebra with minimum grade of C which
means if you could breathe it to a
[ __ ] glass you get into this program
right so yeah and you could probably go
a C in algebra
Wow I even got B's I was good at algebra
was the next level that [ __ ] haha
calculus calculus that was couldn't do
geometry I couldn't do it I could I
don't know why I liked algebra
oh that 3.14 PI you sit here you wait
what the [ __ ] that I ever do it by all
that homework on PI and quarter pi you
never [ __ ] use it in the real world I
would just love to know what jobs
actually do use it like is there a job
somewhere the guy uses PI every day he's
like thank God we use PI I bet there's
at least one guy who uses PI every day
an aerospace engineer I can't believe
for years I've been asking people to
trust me that's people my aides are
doing all this
one of the ways I learned to speak
English when I came from Cuba but
everybody was doing I'm just saying this
that what this is one of the many
weapons that I used to learn English was
the sra reading program and what the SOE
reading program was was a [ __ ] box in
front of your teacher so you teach I had
a desk but right here she had a box and
at the beginning of the year in
September you would get a color like
white you would start like a white belt
and then you had to do a bunch of
assignments in there so not only did you
have to do school homework but jazz to
do the also the SRA readings program
that was one of the things for like
reading class when I do reading from
9:00 tonight at 42 that's what you did
Swire
by our periods in school that's so exact
with the 942 never 99 45 because it's 2
minutes it's 42 minutes of the class and
three minutes free to get to the next
class yeah so every class it says is
perfect so it's said during that three
minutes you find your boyfriend or
girlfriend you make up with them by you
know quick and you gotta run like a
[ __ ] I'm sure you're just
waiting by the door if the teacher
closes the door you gotta go down the
principal got a note to get back the
[ __ ] house oh and if you get three of
those
you gotta you know you don't get
suspended but you get study hall which
means that from from you gotta sit with
a bunch of attention rejects till five
o'clock and throw balloons at each other
and [ __ ] torture each other was
[ __ ] airplanes and [ __ ] you just sent
to the dean's office and they yell at
you [ __ ] like that yeah I got sent to
the principal's office and the principal
couldn't believe that I was in there he
thought I was a good kid cuz he's racist
and I was like in honors and banned and
you know Spanish Honor Society and all
that and I'm sitting there and he's like
well I'm gonna have to revoke the River
Grove mayor's award for good citizenship
now where'd you go to high school is to
cool in in Chicago
what's the name of the high school he's
live in East Leiden white black a little
bit of everything white Mexican no [ __ ]
yeah okay so being the only Asian family
at the high school I was automatically
famous we the only Asian either yeah
everybody know everybody knows the
Asians the Obon came in here last week
uh-huh
and he said he remembers when the first
Asian moved to his neighborhood it was
like a big deal
I wish it was the same neighborhood he
had to save money up and he took like a
cab up then and they waited for him to
walk into the restaurant to see what a
real Asian look like and [ __ ] it's crazy
I didn't know that about yet
yeah well there was one other Asian kid
he was half Korean and half white and he
was a valedictorian and you a second no
I know I was the only other Asian kid in
the high school but I wasn't I was like
number 13 Oh terrible for your parents
whatever 13 that's not really good it's
[ __ ] crazy I don't remember any
Asians in my grammar school in high
school I did but they never really
mingled and you know if you know
anything about me bro I've always been
mystified by everything Asian really
like what oh you do acupuncture no not
but this all started when I was a cure
of my mother every Saturday for a couple
of years my mother would go there was a
place like on now
57th Oh 56th and Bergen wine and it was
a Chinese place that sold like Calif
tiger balm
tiger balm red envelopes for the new
year whose slippers old slipper your wax
expensive I said I found that they can
get Bruce Lee [ __ ] like posters and
numchucks dub chuck the whole book cuz I
used to dress they've thrown stars like
all that stuff no you gotta go missin
you get those I know I had a different
type of I forget with them martial arts
place but the shitty thing about the
stars of them never sharp yeah so you
took him home you today with a [ __ ]
tree you been waiting for three months
to get a star to throw your neighbor's
[ __ ] dog and the next thing that you
throw acid three anything going into the
[ __ ] tree then gonna take it to our
where story sharpen it but they want
like three dollars for each [ __ ] side
there's [ __ ] like it's $26 to get the
star sharp in this [ __ ] you just said
st. 10 months to pay $10 for this star
that cost 26 to sharpen this
[ __ ]
so Plan B is going to your mother's
house and getting a can opener in the
old days and open up cans this way but
if you turn the [ __ ] around
there was a sharpen of a big day it was
taking like four [ __ ] days to sharpen
that start that by the second day just
gave up stars with tough because they
never came sharpened thank goodness
imagine how many like terrors you would
have no Chuck no Chuck she always
modified new chucks came there you
always modified that because at first
when they showed up they just showed up
out of the [ __ ] oak with the string
and then these guerrillas started making
broom handles with the thing but then
Hong Kong Carano the Hong Kong cat came
out and that [ __ ] said it all
because he got plumbing copper plumbing
and he put the caps in the bottom of the
new Chuck so [ __ ] started wow
Krazy Glue in the bottom of compost into
the broom handle like they would get a
broom handle that the thing with it
[ __ ] are clocking you never
mind that if you practice one of those
copper new trucks you'd go home all
[ __ ] up those [ __ ] got all CT
now and [ __ ] I'm surprised I got CT I
hit myself 82 [ __ ] times in the head
with new drugs I do I know I guess I
just play with them on street fighter
you know and play with no chances a
kinematic no you lived your life through
a [ __ ] game the orange ones those are
good yeah we'll start you off with those
to practice with when you were young you
were raised by Korean parents correct
yeah didn't they think of the Taekwondo
the total kicks I don't know my parents
were so [ __ ] cheap didn't take us to
nothing you have sisters correct yeah so
but there's this one guy from church who
lived in our basement and he taught us
Taekwondo as a way to pay my parents
rent so we would learn Taekwondo you
what no a Korean guy straight from Korea
oh he was uh you know probably
30-something no he was decent no I was a
kid so I'm just saying maybe he
breathing on your neck that's what got
you started
took your ice cream they say though yes
cool you know you a little
Esther before that they took you for a
ride you came back as Esther cool yes
well when I was a kid I wasn't cute so
they want you know these guys who lived
in our basement they didn't really try
anything with me oh that probably that
probably saved me though Oh getting
molested you know you become cool Oh
probably when I got like contact lenses
you know that was the glasses yeah but
I've been wearing glasses since I was in
second grade I was a little nerd with
glasses my whole my whole school career
you don't remember anything before your
second grade again pretty every time I
see you is the best you look sad
may your hair looks very nice I went I
went back to black thank you
well you got you changed your head do
you let it grow who's good on you well
you came in here with the hot pants way
[ __ ] around plan with the birth you
made fun of me last time for wearing
pantyhose and I was so embarrassed right
how can America tell people I'm sorry
dad always wearing penny because if they
cheat the mother don't act like you
don't wear pantyhose on the weekends no
I don't [ __ ] know me tell you what's
wrong pantyhose let me tell you
something you know why I never robbed
the bank knowing he knows I'm gonna tell
the truth I never robbed the bank you
don't I [ __ ] despise bad I would
never put a pantyhose over please stop
it please tell me that's not the old let
me tell you something when I was a kid I
don't mind anything I loved I was a
creepy [ __ ] can't do that
nothing like that put on a mask like
they do a baby driver and just let me
have two hours after my dad that I was a
little fun I got a little [ __ ] up how
old are you three anger will [ __ ]
government oh my god Sophie is that that
was a little [ __ ] up that but my mom
and her girlfriend it's a dog sexual
[ __ ] in front like the girls would be
I'd be like six and they'd be playing
cards and I'd be in the other room and I
would hear that girl said mom my husband
finally [ __ ] me the other day he felt
I'm gonna forget what this one lady told
my mom her husband was so [ __ ] up he
ate he fell asleep eating my [ __ ] and
all the other woman will laugh and I was
like eat knows [ __ ] like I didn't
[ __ ] know did you think like they
were literally with a spoon and a bib
eating [ __ ] no you're three you don't
know what eating means I was a little
older than that at that time they would
always get together on Tuesday night and
this one on even till I moved to Jersey
like the group got smaller cuz one got
married one moved away one went to
prison but that central group vivianne
latina they were always together like
la loca whatever they called that forget
all that what her name was it was that
woman was good-looking no no this one
this lady was Gloria her name was Gloria
she was [ __ ] blue-eyed Cuban woman
light skinned your hair colored knockout
when I was a kid I loved that can I had
a crush on him when I was about four
she was my babysitter my mom asked me to
watch me she kept buckling me she
wouldn't let me watch her y5o so I hit a
head with a [ __ ] shoehorn I had when
I was metal shoehorns and [ __ ] so her
and I didn't really talk for like three
or four years and as I got older she
came back into my life but she wasn't my
mom just tired of friends but she wasn't
the dirty one it was this one woman that
I forget what a nameless today her
husband's name was Guillermo but her I
forget what her name was but she would
always talk about sexual escapades with
her husband out loud and I would be in
the room watching like Jesus and I would
hear it I think women talk more about
our sex lives than men do men are just
like yeah I banged her and that's the
end of that it's like yoga going but for
women we get descriptive so I don't you
know it was kind of weird even though my
point was what are we talking about when
you was a kid and you got babysat by the
all.i woman so it was funny but when I
was a kid I was creepy because I got
interested in wonder but I didn't know
anything about was between their legs is
[ __ ] so I would go to my godmothers
house in Miami and she had like a big
bathroom is [ __ ] and I would sniff her
bras
I would sniff a little douchey women in
those days had the rebel thing the
douche with the hose and at the end
there's like a stick that looks kind of
like a dick with like four we're just
walking around with dirty [ __ ]
they put [ __ ] vinegar in the bag and
they shake it up with some Metamucil
disposable whatever you come home they
shake them up it's like [ __ ] no it's
like a Caesar salad dressing yeah it's
the same [ __ ] difference you put that
Caesar salad dressing up your monkey you
keep anybody away for two days did you
ever see her get undressed who that
woman oh wow yeah
you know I watched those dirty woman
yeah they would like women with crazy in
those days because like let's say you
were playing cards and this happened
when I was younger like six five I would
watch them and they were going I love
your blouse and there we go oh you wanna
borrow it yeah oh my god I have a date
tomorrow let me borrow and they would
just take this shirt off and follow me
because it's a way of the word bras
their bras were on their bras they
weren't like titlis no they were never
taken in front of me till this is the
homeless situation my mom wouldn't allow
this [ __ ] there's no tits and then you
know boom that was a way my mom would
ask me when they would leave my mom go
break it down train you to be that way
yeah she was like what are you thinking
about Vivian she's like trying to get
that like testosterone [ __ ] around
is that what Cubans mom do yeah when I
was 12 she brought a woman home one
night and thinking back today like I
could look you straight in the face and
I would tell you and they [ __ ] each
other I don't remember if she took me
upstairs uh-huh
and I woke up next to her but I think I
had like an anxiety attack until today
50 40 years later I still don't know
what really happened I know we made a
little bit your mom's friend my mom woke
me up and saying get dressed there's
somebody downstairs who wants to meet
you and it was my dad my stepdad [ __ ]
not my dad my stepdad no no I don't
think so a bunch of women no no scam you
just [ __ ] up my emotions don't do that
to a Cuban that's not the way I want to
lose my virginity and how I was like 12
I'll never forget this I went downstairs
not really knowing what she was talking
about
how could you you're 12 man went down
with pajamas you know the pajamas are
you feed them mm-hmm I got went down
like a little heifer fruit we're gonna
doorway for you're like a super bar like
a [ __ ] superhero or football player
Batman and we had when we pulled into a
garage there were stairs going up and
stairs going down stairs going up took
into the kitchen Stan's going down my
mom and I separate it was like a room
with a TV and a bar and a refrigerator
and that's when they cooked sometimes
down there was like a separate place for
jira
no it was like 15 people I used it as a
as a as a karate room like I well how
does it kid me and my friends are gonna
beat the fun out of each other
but my mom's like you can't make holes
in the walls no more so she fixed it up
and turned it into like a [ __ ] hang
now I used to go in there watch TV at
night and I went downstairs I was like
15 people that I'd do a lot of the guys
from my mom's bar and also my mom was
like what do you think you know like I
don't even know what the [ __ ] I said and
Nixie don't ever play music and my mom
was like dancers I'm like no and she's
like the answer this camera but I
started dancing and she started rubbing
up against me I'm gonna tell you
something my dick got hard at 12'o my
dick that's so hard that my pajamas
you've gone through puberty yet no I was
late I was all they bloom I'm like I I
was when I was one of those guys with it
at first your hair grows on the sides
and your kid may be a girl I know for us
the hague ruin the side so like that
Jude the hair grew would thicken the
side not the top though so I kept
telling people I'm ready I'll be ready
to [ __ ] by September oh my September the
rest of that dry patch you're [ __ ]
filling in a while it took eight months
for that [ __ ] to fill in
so I was excited to [ __ ] but I couldn't
[ __ ] with no hair you know that's just
against God you have to flower you
shaved it off already
nobody trusts me you're 13 nobody shaves
their deck they want everybody lives
their whole life to get that first
[ __ ] man yeah and Esther did you
shave you a little monkey when you first
got every 13 okay [ __ ] 20 yeah that's
people doing [ __ ] like that so I didn't
know but it's so funny how the hair
comes in the sides and you know I [ __ ]
look how fast a hanger on the sides but
it took eight months for the [ __ ] you
were walking around like a bozo dick but
he was just bald so no no no no there
was no no no I took her upstairs we
danced
you know we danced there everybody was
like giggling and [ __ ] and then she goes
come on let me take you upstairs she had
like a dress on I think we swap spit man
because I had a room upstairs the Attic
and I had my bedroom downstairs there
was three bedrooms on the second floor
and an attic that was turned into a
bedroom there was also bathroom on that
floor we will up to the attic I didn't
take out my bedroom and we swapped a
little Spanish shape when I woke up in
the morning I was so petrified that's
too cool I didn't see if she was naked
of that I was so [ __ ] embarrassed
because I everybody always wants to have
sex but you have a certain way that's
[ __ ] crazy as this is I always had
always opposed gonna be a a different
[ __ ] white I can't it's a stupid
dirty [ __ ] when I was a kid I had sex
with some [ __ ] in some creepy
situations man what did you do play
doctor with the kids I didn't use a
condom like the first like three or four
times I was just like and I and I was no
need to what do you mean you do
especially after your your guy you know
got full blast in 85 it's lucky you
didn't become a team - oh well no I
didn't have sex 104 85 the Arab League
still ran the [ __ ] gamut I think I
started getting diseases Lincoln [ __ ]
oh Jesus that's how wars night when the
80s getting diseases
[ __ ] man that's the AIDS era 85 was 83
was one day
started [ __ ] or something like that I
watched that movie let the music play or
whatever it's called on HBO about the
pilot who supposedly spread it you know
in the beginning Richard Gere's the
[ __ ] dude he get AIDS he plays the
[ __ ] dude that I forget what is
there's like one patient zero I think
we'll the guy who started AIDS really
you know I don't know you can't really
say it I think it was attached to a
pilot huh who gave it to a stewardess
you know it was just they showed the
chart of what they thought I think they
had it if you watch that movie watch it
sometime let the music play or the band
played on it's got everybody in it I
mean it's kind of got a whole star
[ __ ] cast HBO did it 30 [ __ ] years
ago
and all that stuff started in 85 an 84
85 I was still taking chances
I took chances to about 93 oh [ __ ] a
hole that drug you know we get drugged
up and you're doing blow when you having
sex at 5:00 in the morning you've been
up your ability to make decisions
dissipate so you're just oh here goes it
goes for nothing and you're sticking in
there yelling what if there's like a
helmet in there well you know you don't
know so you just simply take a chance
then something you go to the doctor and
get an HIV test you come back clean you
know god I owe you one
the next time you see a dude in front of
a 7-eleven instead I give him a dollar
get my final bill give one back the
[ __ ] comments the truth what can you
do there you go
you're lucky you went through some crazy
[ __ ] we're all [ __ ] lucky you know
when you're a it's funny last night I
went through the store and everyone was
up and she was talking about men
comedian how they all cheat on their
wives that felt the animals
that's why they were all the voice
you're pretty [ __ ] funny
I guess the majority of them it's and
it's wow you know you're still married
yeah I've been without for 17 [ __ ]
years man yeah lot goes on in 17 14
years a long time but you know you get
the levels in your life and you'll sing
you know you guys are young you see and
after you get there you go oh now I
understand why this happened well I
pretty much plays itself out and you see
at different levels for me to get to the
next level I needed a wife I needed that
man around being no no it's not a
grounding man once your man is young and
I think there are plenty of female
comics who cheat on their husbands to
really you never listen nobody really
knows who the [ __ ] it was a [ __ ] but
it's it's not even about that it's like
that what's the point in it I don't even
[ __ ] know we're talking about you
threw me off with that [ __ ] [ __ ]
marry you and I'm to the edge in my
story
we're like you're all lucky why you got
married you'll see listen you were
pulling up right and you'll see after
you were poorer for 15-20 years you'll
see the part that she plays in your life
but it's hard to describe to somebody
like now when I was a youngster and I
got married I didn't really have any
respect for it when I was 28 when I got
married I don't marriage was I worked I
come home I give me a stand in the house
is clean I really did and that's a
[ __ ] horrible way to think but guess
what that's how 60% of guys go into it
well they getting something out of the
deal the father owns a construction
company and you know there's always a by
the way because guys don't really know
they want to get married everybody wants
to get married
everybody's raised to get [ __ ]
married and also you get married you
make a mistake in there you [ __ ] up
and then you learn about yourself you
bounce back a few years you learn about
yourself and guess what man you find
some
who you truly understands you and you
understand that person and the next
thing you know you wit them for five
years and then you get married then
you're with them for 10 years then
you're with them for 15 years and you
see the growth that you've done together
you needed that growth to take you into
your different level of manhood that's a
complete different level of manhood you
know and it's okay if you made a mistake
when you were married as long as you got
married the second time you made a good
choice you found the right one for you
cuz every ass has the seat I don't give
a [ __ ] what they tell you every ass has
a seat and guess what that's that only
you're gonna kiss 20 people before you
find the right person but when you do
you'll know it first marriage is always
for [ __ ] up well say that but III
always smell like those more practical
wedding cards to give to my friends when
they get married the first time around
like I give it five years no you gotta
be positive with people but the beauty
about it is you know when it's a
[ __ ] wedding and you know what it's
real mm-hmm if I see you too you know
you've got a wedding to me they're the
most [ __ ] pretentious thing that you
ever do in your life whether you're an
actress
you're a pornography or a [ __ ]
accountant they make you sick to your
stomach when is make you sick to your
stomach because it's like a three-hour
somebody turned ether on and then you
hear crazy [ __ ] you go they kissed 80
times they had [ __ ] every celebrity
there they shot pigeons in the air
they had Mercedes Benz but the night
before Mario Lopez and his friends took
a stripper and [ __ ] her up the ass and
caming him up his [ __ ] and she went
public and the chick that he married
[ __ ] and got the marriage and all of
them Monday no way that's what happened
yeah look it up man marriage for
cheating you know something about that
think about how many times a secretary
goes good for her that she annulled it
think about it think about how many
times a secretary goes to a wedding
and her boss and his wife a kiss him and
that's saying to forever and people
don't know he saw one love me why you
like I just sucked his dick three nights
ago he ate my [ __ ] and he gave me $5
how many funerals do like the mistresses
or the side dicks come up and there as
you look at them like well why are they
extra crying so hard because that their
rent is getting cut off that electric
light bill is [ __ ] done you know I'm
saying that account
you're the electrician and you comes out
again [ __ ] yeah I see now it's just
really crazy how what the [ __ ] was that
and the Maya Lopez coming you know the
story was him something that always
bothered me about weddings you go to a
wedding and while you're there I really
gotta be honest here I could sit there
and call the times people gonna get
divorced there's no big all the time man
no no no I went to my friend's wedding
she met him on tinder and they broke up
a year later I'm like why did I waste
money on your [ __ ] present I said the
same to my [ __ ] back I want my [ __ ] back
under you know before I am like it just
so specially when I bought I bought
something from for her on William Sonoma
on the website and then went then
something that she requested that I
bought wasn't available until September
so they sent me a gift card for the
amount that I spent because there was
like a fluke in the system I could have
told her right then that the marriage
wasn't gonna work let me ask you this
you still tour a lot yeah you still
doing colleges yeah no not so much
colleges what about that girl called you
were dropping on
is this film on TV I don't [ __ ] know
all right you know I was into the first
three seasons of girlcode' is this still
on TV probably you don't know either
give me a [ __ ] straight answer you
know I don't know be [ __ ] no I
Korean you got every penny you don't
know we don't pay residuals no no you
just pay one time and c'est la vie they
can play it though you [ __ ] yeah so it
doesn't benefit me if they replay it so
it might be airing but I don't know but
you make your money on the road that's
what that's what you're supposed that's
the MTV model I guess did you find it
yeah yeah yeah print it up on the thing
that readeth up that's the coke or what
this little attack that alright
meanwhile they had pictures of him I
truly love Mario Lopez oh it's [ __ ]
ugly and then in late there's another
art of love gonna pull up I saw and I
just read the headline it said he admits
to never loving her thing that's almost
worse than cheating after it's a master
she got it annulled don't publicly say I
never loved you
Oh cuz he got embarrassed and I've heard
you know people last time we spoke about
this couple of years ago we really got
into it we got into this conversation oh
we got this conversation with so many
years ago that got heavy maybe la Savage
I would feel like a pedophile [ __ ]
Mario Lopez with those stupid dimples
you know he looks so young
what's-her-name will you please Mahlon
Ali Ali Lane yes this chick was a model
she did something
Jesus Christ why are their heads cut off
no Mario Lopez he [ __ ] around do you
want to see if I can finally get like a
real in-depth that's why you can't get
married around spring break that's what
happened here everybody at the party was
on Spring Street you used to a certain
[ __ ] lifestyle you're not gonna give
up that lifestyle if you look like Mario
Lopez you get [ __ ] five nights a week
in this town just being Mariel Lopez all
sudden he meets a girl he falls dead
because everybody thinks they gonna fall
in love I think he remarried now he's
yeah here's a daughter now but yeah it
don't matter
all those celebrity types are
good-looking they're always there's
always somebody who's gonna suck that
dick in a closet or in a car real quick
do you think they appreciate it anymore
well he's been getting his dick sucked
in Saved by the Bell days yeah that's
amazing
you're a man you always appreciate it no
it's what are you gonna call get bored
and start [ __ ] dudes I think I think
I appreciate blow jobs more than Mario
Lopez planning get them as much how do i
do know that ridiculousness seems there
yeah it's [ __ ] that's me how often do
you get [ __ ] I'm not complaining I'm
just saying overall compared to Mario
Lopez as like a oh poor way please whoa
you don't think so always he has enough
situations going on what are you leaving
for Vegas my brother Friday morning
you ready to go tip-top Magoo yeah my
god playing cards what are you doing
dude playing cards we're gonna go see
the UH the Beatles show there that'll be
good and I think that huh what do you
have against Cirque du Soleil just
curious what made you pick the Beatles
no I played twenty two hours you never
asked me wants to put on the Beatles cuz
she wants to see Beatles and there's a
million of them oh I've seen the Beatles
show yeah people love it yeah it's
really good everyone says I'm not even a
big Beatles person I'm a Beach Boys
person okay a Beach Boys are good and
we're gonna we're gonna watch the fights
with Larry and I'm pretty excited so
entertaining about watching a fight well
it's it's in a cool little blam prefer
to watch real fights on the street
that's good we can't bet on those one
time in New York
I saw it was like 2:00 in the morning
this couple was having a fight they were
screaming at each other in the East
Village OSA then she takes her shirt off
and she has no bra on she's has big
boobs she jumps in a taxi in the
backseat jumps out the other side of the
door he runs after her and they're
screaming at the top of their lungs
those are the kinds of fights I like to
watch me to esta cool but then you grow
the [ __ ] up and you go why the [ __ ]
would I want to sit here in case this
guy starts taking a knife and coming at
me I see in life I see a fight in New
York City you take a look and you keep
walking if somebody drops a wallet and
you run back and pick it up mm-hmm and
you take the cash any mail in the mail
but no you [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know
esta cool why why he's gonna watch the
UFC fight Jon Jones is fighting Cormier
so he's gonna [ __ ] Vegas for this
[ __ ] girlfriend you don't wanna watch
it alive I don't have like street fights
every like it's unreliably are you gonna
given that you got a list of ready yeah
we're gonna take a stroll right what
else and then we're gonna go to a woman
of Fae I think all right what else and
that's all I think that's all we have
planned so far but Izzie there's no how
much place and [ __ ] Vegas or something
why why I go to Vegas and get hummus I
can bring because that's what you do
that's the type of person but a babies
and get Hummers sure he won't my Hummer
he's gonna go to be those shows that
they're like a more to Luke yeah they
have a tip 14 or 20 whatever cirque du
soleil show is good there's no one goes
[ __ ] going nowhere I'm gonna play
blackjack drive for six hours four hours
you split a 140 degree weather
[Laughter]
he's going to drive five hours to Vegas
yeah everyone drives to Vegas it's fun
that's a long trip that's a long trip on
a Friday morning how much is a flight
like 60 bucks
there's no baby if you know if you know
when you're going for our four years in
advance now it's like driving though I
like what I have for him trust well no
it's not plus if you if you like measure
the time from you leaving your house get
even if you're just going to Burbank and
then that whole process it's maybe you
save an hour maybe I don't know probably
6:00 a.m. I don't I don't [ __ ] around
it's Vegas I don't [ __ ] around space
well probably but wake up but it's exam
and get on the road to beat the traffic
and get what do you pull out at a
blackjack game when you're up how by
home see that's my problem when I'm
around
Dawg listen he loses every [ __ ] best
you know but that's it when I wouldn't
use that I pull out plus okay
do you play have you ever had a friend
there with you listen why are we talking
about black no no let's please boki is
both these you know what a turtle a
blackjack
this guy got so bad at it trust me a
year ago he's only a blackjack player he
was going on every night ebooks if
there's asian dealer do you not sit
there yeah sometimes they're so fast or
too good yeah well the minim men I'll
sit down women are just they're real
fast and they're kind of like I was at
the stratosphere and I did really well
there but they were just so cranky
sometimes like I'll get me a good time
with the oh the Chinese dealers
yeah sometimes women sometimes a little
nothing not too happy to be there that's
when you got a dough some with edible I
would love to do that that would be so
much fun what's your favorite place in
Vegas to play cards the other happy it's
the most comfortable ah I like anywhere
I mean it really doesn't matter I have a
whole foot cards over you used to be
like the renews you don't have you
written a yelp review for I've never
written a yelp reviews I used to like
playing in the Venetian but they have
real
like I think like when I first started
going to Vegas parking was free and
every casino even valet you tip the guy
and now it's look like you have to pay
everybody charges yeah everyone charges
everyone chart and it's a pain in the
butt and it seems like they've really
raised the table limit Vegas your
parking this week 40 a day going to day
I'm more there for today so look you
made sure that you ain't paying that two
and a half day you get now there I'm the
ticket if I know you I'm all know I'm
sure how tip-top Magoo Jeff I'll check
out probably 11 but yeah it's gonna I
mean the Venetian is really great I had
a really good time
and they're like the lock it's either
the locks or I think well maybe the
castle it's like it's all connected to
Mandalay Bay and the last time I was
there that's where I had like a really
good time like that was my best singer
Lee put Paula to bed after the Beatles
right know by yourself you probably and
but I am gonna get her she's a good yeah
but you know that you don't pull out
early enough I'm gonna bring her with me
sir with behind you oh my god he's never
had the opportunity of bono right how
much do you put down
no nothing 150 though that I'm paying
for a hundred bucks
uh-huh and that's you went up to 450
ones no I wanna I went up to with a
thousand one sigh so this is the it was
it was the I was doing terrible all
weekend it was like that's how I did get
[ __ ] on the drive there was an
accident right out the border and took
two hours across the border that's how
my did get [ __ ] and let it's always
happens I'm always our friend Larry said
that it was a bad mood ooh but I went to
strip steak
you were very nicely pay for any time we
had a dinner strip steak and he gave me
a hundred bucks for gambling so like
this is Joey's I go in I walk into the
casino I don't know more like playing by
myself cuz it's a little fast and like
you can lose a lot real quick you like
playing with yourself I do that also but
there's a black dude dealer and I just
went down no one was there on him I just
started getting Black Jacks but and it's
funny you brought up the
Blackjacks Blackjacks Blackjacks he
leaves an Asian woman and starts pulling
and I just went probably from 1 to 300
let's say no more face cards and I was
real excited ok there's Nate I'm gonna
leave but something was she I she I
think she even said something I think
she was even like give me a Chancellor
or where you going and I said ok let's
try it again
I got like maybe like seven black jacket
over the span of like 15 minutes it was
amazing and like it was the only time I
used to bet $15 at certain points to
deal was making my bed 225 or they
wanted to switch the table but it was
like the best run of cards I've ever
gone and I think when I left there I had
one from you're one to like six or four
of something someone in that area I'm
gonna walk to another casino and I just
ended up sitting down on a 25 dollar
table by accident and when you're on
those tables it's actually kind of cool
because you sit with people who are like
real gamblers they come in with stacks
and and they'll bet like 400 a hand
three hands over like the table and it's
like it's way more than I could ever bet
but it's like exciting for me to even
just see it happen but I I took it up to
a thousand and I told myself I was gonna
leave I didn't and I even I missed the
shuttle if I had if I if I had left in
time for the shuttle I would have went
to a TAS and I'm left with 500 so it
still I still did okay but I I lost half
of it damn it was terrible yeah time
your pullouts with the shuttle I'm not
good at it yeah I mean I've started
setting timers on my phone
you know what's crazy the the psychology
of gambling you know I never
it was almost years I sports but I could
count on my hands how many times I
really picked up an envelope because
even if you're up you're always greedy
right greed always comes up
unless you're [ __ ] super strong and
super willed and over the years you know
you get a little bit more control when
you see what they're doing and then you
see this am
you know you start to see more things
and you become less of a percentage
yeah percentages are less than losing
money and you just won by going you know
I know when I first started doing them I
always do a parlay and you always tell
me probably as always lose
just pick one friend I think that's one
do with this fight I think I like one
fight and I think I'm gonna go with that
very crazy are you betting on the fight
I think so people always tell me why do
you always get a sumo why are you so
broke because the only and there's only
two cars I could possibly buy on the
road right now do you know why because I
sold cars in college and I sold cars and
I was good at it
and I saw the scam I saw the beginning
the middle and the end
and because of that I remember
everything about cars like I only buy
cars unless I got a great great deal or
it's a two-year-old cause for somebody
else eats the appreciation of the
appreciation whatever the [ __ ] you call
it that's the only way I would buy a
[ __ ] car but besides that I would
never buy a car but without those two
key witnesses you know why would that
buy a BMW nothing like that because I
know as a young guy I saw what those
cars represent and they always made me
feel shitty
you know same way why would I have a car
and I don't know I don't need a [ __ ]
me MW for the first time I got into a
BMW you know you're like whoa you always
think like it's so far away you know you
always only been in Toyota's and Fords
and Chevys and the first time I was like
good you know probably I don't know but
the first time I got in when I was like
wow this is their beautiful car just
people the other people the other people
live yeah
just made me feel weird she made you
feel like you have to like talk quieter
have you ever been anyone like they even
fancier cars like the Rolls Royces or
like I've never even been in like that's
crazy like $100,000 cars and we mean oh
my gosh we drive to the restaurant
Alembic
tase them guys I feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I got out of that car
I really do I can't want it because of
the way your colored time we meet now I
just go let me just me the restaurant
because I don't want to pull up in a
Lamborghini and I'm gonna pull up in a
car with a cause where the doors go up
on this side like a rocket ship
first of all like of McLaren yeah like
first for the first coffee no one I'm
not comfortable in those [ __ ] cause
I'm a big do it number two I just can't
pull up in front of a place and come out
of that [ __ ] car smokes coming out
yeah like I can't feel this has never
been for me I don't like sports cars cuz
I don't like being so close to the
ground it feels weird it feels like a
truck could run you over they do I don't
know sometimes well they're very close
to the ground that's why I'm like are
they oh I mean I don't need to be high
up on an SUV but I'd rather just be
regular height with regular where I used
to have
I bought it twice in a row and I got to
be too low for me I'm like this is too
[ __ ] well and I was about to give up
two months ago I was about to give up
guys cuz there was only one car beside
that Subaru really like I wanted to try
that's the Cadillac meet him that was it
besides that I'm a Subaru guy and I was
driving down my block and I saw a car
not like my wife but the other one it's
a little smaller and cuter and I said
let me get in that I loved it it's
perfect with little hi I'm not looking
to [ __ ]
I'm not looking at Johnny Lamborghini or
nothing like that I'm just trying to put
the [ __ ] pieces together but
yeah you're always doing something I'm
really proud of you for putting the
elbows show you're still working with
the same manager oh yeah um on my show I
just had a live podcast taping with Aiko
Tanaka and and Kevin Shea Michael tomato
she's the girl that was a comic 20 years
ago at the store that woman oh no it was
a big time Japanese woman then hung on
what some practice you dated Sam Kinison
I go something from The Comedy Store in
the eighties and nineties real pretty
Japanese girl I think she's back in
Japan don't once and I'm there last time
I saw her she was at this I heard about
her I never met her yeah yeah cool and
stuff ran with the [ __ ] outlaws real
crazy [ __ ] Asian no I co was a model
and she was on Howard Stern before she
became a comedian little I thought yeah
like was a cute girl yeah she's got me
the shades are bad mother [ __ ] caller
yes no Kevin Shea along I just posted
that episode today coup and the gang is
my podcast who in the [ __ ] Kool
and the gang so you got a little TV show
mm-hmm you got the podcast where are you
soon where you goin on the road soon I'm
gonna be at the Bayshore Club in Miami
on August 7th and they book comics there
all the time
yeah what's going on with the dorm
improv have you seen it yet
have you heard rumors I don't know
what's going on with the Darrell yeah
but I heard it's opening yes yes well
they gonna have a club in Miami pretty
soon we can both work that [ __ ]
yeah good time Esther cuckoo the Korean
thank you see that Cuban bread [ __ ] yeah
esta cool so both your parents are
Korean yeah well my mom just died I'm
sorry
by all was she so she was 64 okay yeah
that bad you know say Mazel Tov yeah you
miss her you know um you you know you
reminisce yeah how was your relationship
mother wasn't good better with your dad
no worse with you dad no I mean like you
know I've been through therapy so my
therapist once I told them about my
parents they like advised me not to you
know really hang out with my parents
anymore but I used to do you know what I
mean like you're cold you become
codependent and [ __ ] and I used to do
things for her all the time I cleaned
her room one time she was still messy
she was like a kid I cleaned my mom's
bedroom one time and I found like worms
and like papers from like 1994 you know
some people just don't know how to but
she was a big gambler Korean yeah yeah
and she would like she would gamble so
much and Illinois that she had to like
get herself on like a list of like in
Gamblers Anonymous they have you do like
you know but like if you win anything
you have to give it back like you sign
yourself up to do that so what was she
gambling on she was playing she wouldn't
even play blackjack Lee what you playing
yes tiger claw machine yes yes no dicta
those she would be especially would win
$11,000 $13,000 buy a car and then not
be able to pay the taxes and then you
know and then and I lose it all back
wait hurry your dad's still married yeah
you dad know about the gambling mm-hmm
some more mm-hmm because he's not he's
not like that I'm not like that
yeah she would go crazy she just no
beacon to the night down there you know
my mom married my dad and my dad was a
poor guy but my mom came from a nice
family you know she was like she she
like I when I went to Korea and I'm
my relatives I was like oh my mom's side
they're all like doctors and my dad's
side they're all like taxi drivers she
like married down that's why she was
addicted to gambling probably because
she didn't have any money what they do
for a living
my dad was a worked at the post office
overnight and my mom was a nurse a
little bit of money but yeah like nine
kids two kids five kids
no but they made them give 20% of their
money away to the church Oh
what church the church that I grew up in
yeah the Korean church with the valence
evangelical church you know they had
cars yeah as I seen like a little Korean
chili they couldn't afford a van they
were the church was in a house they like
took took a house and knocked the walls
down all the neighbors hated us what
were they doing with all that money
um it would there's a lot of poor people
at the church so they would just like
pay for people's apartments or help
people help people pay for their wedding
rings and [ __ ] like that what anyone's
that's a luxury yeah no bleep I'll help
you pay for an apartment I know
welcome to get a meal yeah to get a warm
blanket
broke ex-drug addicts were members of
the church and I don't want to say
ex-drug addicts but it was just like a
lot of you imagine paying 20 percent on
top of taxes dude I know man definitely
like we didn't have anything because all
the money went to the church and then I
worked for the church also you know
crazy dog like it was a church dick yeah
all right I give the church dick I go
that put a fin of the basket
I feel comfortable with the skinny
fitting you know saying after that you
got to [ __ ] talk to me they give you
a little bit more than I got friends in
Nino I know friends that need help
that's a cathode for me that's the
Catholic way I said me going to a church
and giving 10% listen every [ __ ]
month I either send money to my sister
oh my god
I got no choice anymore my godmother I
got to pay for our [ __ ] electric bill
in Miami it's 170 a month in the [ __ ]
winter in the summer with the air
conditioner with that condition because
the air conditioner Jackson up or
something like that so I get it you know
I'm saying I get it that's a Catholic
boy I take care of my family
besides that will your mid do give you
10 points of my action 20 points of my
action for what to go there and play the
tambourine so I can let people know how
good of a dude I am so at the end of the
if people [ __ ] st. let's let's give
it up for the Diaz family for also being
part of the [ __ ] suckers on the list
and everybody claps well just go to
church because they're lonely people go
to church for various reasons I go to
church from time to time I'm not making
fun anybody who goes to church
I just went to church early on and
seeing what it was - a lot of people you
get it I see what it is to you Lee said
he went to that [ __ ] the Rocky Horror
Picture Show
- some people people don't like - okay
but for some dude I saw it 69 times you
know I was here when that was Susan
Sarandon walk then that type of [ __ ] you
know he wouldn't hang you know with me I
remember one time it was the summer
maybe the winter of 81 and that's a
Fairview cinema which was a double
cinema at midnight they would always
play at rocky our pictures showing
something else some nights it was Pink
Floyd live in Pompeii or then they had a
Neil Young movie they had a bunch of
movies in cinah late 70s and one time it
was the song remains the same so me
lubes our way and Glen card the inferni
tribe up the ferry cinema which is a
mile from well ahead call this was so
you could I walked it sometimes
somewhere he's saying out and we were
all pretty cool at that time I mean I
grew up in that era with punk music in
the city and my friend it was gay so he
would always tell me about CBGB's and
all that stuff like that and I knew
about Rocky Horror Picture Show and
between you and me it wasn't for me he's
just lying in that [ __ ] so I paid my
four bucks
forever the midnight movie was but out
of the four of us there was one dude who
I know it wasn't gonna work out for him
if he wanted that his name was Roger
Holloway Roger didn't play nothing like
that he them talk to people in long hair
he didn't like that twos he didn't like
greasy hair he didn't like marijuana he
[ __ ] hated people smoked marijuana
every time I sparked that my front of me
he will lose his [ __ ] mind so we walk
into this movie theater and I and look
at him and he goes I gotta go pee and
also I sit down I get my popcorn I get
my soda
I walk through the middle of movie teeth
I sit down and next thing you [ __ ]
know like I forget all about and next to
him and I hear [ __ ] you know [ __ ] you
you put your [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
yeah I'm not yet he's young he's y'all
knows like I'll drop you like cancer you
[ __ ] and he say no I should I go
that's Roger I turn around and he's got
like three of those rocky horror picture
shows guys outside the box and I go
what's the problem suppose these [ __ ]
guys I walked into the wrong theater he
went back into that theater and he
wasn't prepared for that he wasn't in
for that by no means the rest of us like
I said if we walked in there we'd be
high I just walk in there sit and giggle
but this guy was too much room he's a
boxing match I turn around this [ __ ]
Roger telling I [ __ ] you get the [ __ ]
back in there before I'll drop you like
cancer don't
oh my God look jumping up and down I
like it no no it's too much Runkle Joe
it was too I'm telling you man when I
was 21 22 older girlfriend in Snowmass
Village
she lived in Basalt I lived in Snowmass
she was 27 of 29 she went for the wines
I don't [ __ ] know this girl
next thing always started having sex she
introduced me to brie cheese and wine
brie cheese crackers are one like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] is mold you like
brie cheese 3 cheese she was from
Milwaukee she was the Italian girl but
she wanted me to meet her at the rocky
our picture show and I was like I got
time for [ __ ] fun and games I'm gonna
go see trading places with my gorilla
buddies saw what does he trained in
places [ __ ] the legend that he
Murphy at that time we never talked how
do you guys break up then we just never
spoke again that [ __ ] happens
that shouldn't happen nowadays these
kids they like to see each other on link
on social media after they break up and
they dump each other on its axis [ __ ]
and then you like look up who the new
girlfriend or new boyfriend right it's
better to just like leave each other and
never look up each other ever again I
was in love with a girl one time dawg I
was in love with her guys I mean it was
[ __ ] real I was in love with her and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] crackle act 35 years ago
we can we crack a laugh that just
graduate I just didn't graduate I quit
high school but it was that summer when
I was supposed to graduate we were in
love and then for a month we kind of
argue
and I robbed the [ __ ] jewelry store
and had to leave town no what was over
you don't saying she saw me for what I
was
it's so [ __ ] weird man and what's the
point in what we thought being in love
[ __ ] happens to you happens wouldn't you
like have like these blinders on doesn't
love so blinding it really is like we
just talked I left when I got back seven
months later she was dating a dear
friend of mine
I never said boo it was that I went to a
dear friend of Mines house to hang out
it just happened yet he was a coke
dealer and she was there and that's the
first time I saw since a little
rendezvous like how are you mean
something like what time nothing good to
see you good to see you ba ba ba ba ba
and we basically spoke one time after
that and she asked me never to call her
again 1985 and that's what your life is
made of sometimes called her what would
have a reaction have been if I called
him you know she's like don't ever call
me again but then what if a year later
you called her what do you think she
would she was in love there was no
reason to call what she was already in
love with a different doing I'm not even
a friend of mine she went met a
different dude and he had her on the
straight and narrow she wasn't out
drinking the war or party and that was
it
nobody ever saw again and she's not even
on Facebook our friends are on Facebook
and when they hang out I see the
pictures of her nothing it's like
nothing ever happened
but that's part of your life you know
saying like the you gonna mean a
thousand people some you gonna keep in
touch with something in jizz with in the
first place and so I mean I can I throw
this people I still look for on a
constant level dude named Keith cool
place to call Cato from 83 to 87 I was
tight with Cato
he was my weak connection to [ __ ]
Aspen Snowmass but basalt he lived down
valley when I [ __ ] split he took my
safe I was tight with Cato dug that was
my dawg
that's thousands of people at some
nights the middle night should remember
the name and I got up and Google their
name
nothing Google were they last when I
think about it nothing
this ways to Google to find people I'm
just not a pro at I'm not a prior to
messing in there's ways that you get
right to it
I google people from my grade school to
can't be found the worst one for me just
talking about exes and stuff like that I
hate when they block you want social
media that drives me bananas they block
you yeah well when you break up with the
winner after you break down oh really I
don't know buddy like that you broke up
with you is there any reason to talk to
you no but don't burn it the blocking is
it's just I don't even am I gonna talk
to you why waste a number if the [ __ ]
yeah yeah when I'm love them what you
want to talk about no I don't really
love you think I don't love them that's
the one I understand heartbreak but let
me tell you something I took such a
heartbreak in the seventh grade that I
got looked back for it the heartbreak
was painful
painful has to go in the seventh grade I
was in love with a chick I thought I'd
run in front of a [ __ ] bus line this
I was great what did you guys go out we
do a lot of things that's to Co
everything but sex we would dry hump
[ __ ] like that listen to music never did
drugs fell in love she told me we're
gonna have sex and she said she wanted a
weight and that put me into a tailspin I
couldn't even focus just dry-hump enough
would make my heart beat I'm saying like
just the whole mystery of what happened
at that age really till this day it was
just weird at that age I hope I hope no
I hold no hell will die it's weird
well how old are you the first time you
are appropriate um probably 2020 why do
you break your heart I was oh I was old
already you were you were only in
seventh grade what's the [ __ ]
difference because like I just I never I
had never gone out with anybody in grade
school or high school you know yeah yeah
like I never I never lost my virginity I
went to my freshman year of college a
full virgin the whole [ __ ] year and
then my sophomore year I got a boyfriend
and and we went out and I we would like
write each other [ __ ] letters did you
write letters yes yeah I would we would
write letters and we would like I would
like read his letter and he would read
my letter and I would just like cry with
him you know like my first few
boyfriends I just cried like the whole
relationship you know like it was it was
like there guy hadn't been to therapy
yet so the whole relationship I'm just
crying you know you ever have a
girlfriend it just doesn't stop crying
why are you crying what the [ __ ] are you
crying about just crying just I had to
like I couldn't cry when I was a kid
like you know you said you're mystified
by Asian cultures
and like Asians I mean Koreans like they
don't really let you cry it's a very
much he's mo culture so if you cry like
you're a little [ __ ]
and you can't even like cry in front of
your family so you would have all this
built-up anger or you know sadness that
you couldn't express in front of your
brother or sister or your mom or dad and
so I would be in my room crying by
myself you know like with the door
closed like you can't you can't cry in
public
it's crazy my daughter's going through
that phase right now when she has a
nervous breakdown and it drives me
[ __ ] crazy like I can't [ __ ] deal
with and I keep my cool you know me I'm
a [ __ ] gentle boy talk door but deep
down inside it drives me crazy
so something happen at the pool last
week water gotta have knows that she got
scared I don't [ __ ] know some my wife
signs around with swimming classes we
don't want to say we get there and she
brazen to her face she don't wanna go
[ __ ] this one
that she's scared of water you know she
was crying this [ __ ] and I just
listening today held her and I just so
blessed so long we just said I don't put
your feet in the water if you don't want
to go and you don't have to go in but if
you wanna go when you jump up with the
rest of the kids and the instructor and
I went and sat with my wife with some
friends and it was crazy because I had
me a co-op she was sitting there I was
breaking my [ __ ] line I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill scan the goddamn water what
the [ __ ] that I do if I'm is late she
jumped in head first so that [ __ ] was
for nothing
you know same it's too late tonight I
mean how many more times is that gonna
happen I mean I look like tonight I was
sitting there on the computer she came
as he goes daddy can i watch you
completely oh sure I go to youtube my
ass girl I told the spell it out she
writes it in after 20 minutes I could
sit down I go let me take a hike I'll
leave me here by yourself well I know
the condition I know exactly how I leave
them notebooks I gotta hide everything I
gotta hide the Wiis everything when
she's around but I know she's gonna
snoop it's in her nature to the gene
that's who I am
so two minutes later I said I don't sell
the two minutes I hit my mother pop I
don't say a [ __ ] word I my wife
sitting there rubbing her toes a little
[ __ ] she's doing not me I know that I
know I know annoys at that I know a
noise of [ __ ] snooping and I look at
it and she's busted out crying daddy I
moved in your picture fell now the
picture she drew for me is [ __ ] three
goes to some [ __ ] on my wall I know
what happened I think was I'm so sorry
she got up and hung I go why the hell
are you crying I don't know yeah why are
you quiet the [ __ ] crying buddy then
don't look it's an accident right yeah
okay give me a hug can we kiss go sit
down and stop crying okay it drives me
crazy when she cries she doesn't know
why she's crying
she's my little boy and it drives me
crazy I work at out Willa but it's every
[ __ ] day three times a day I talk to
about this show if Lisa if Joey Diaz was
your dad would you cry I would never do
that that's all I was told I reason with
her like she's an adult awk to her like
that
yeah that's how you're supposed to talk
to kids yeah what are you feeling
Express your words like that [ __ ] she's
a year away from being like a medium kid
she's gotta understand these things so
what's the problem so now a toddler no
she's worn a half [ __ ] table
she hasn't crawled in three [ __ ]
years she's running all [ __ ] day long
when she gets home she's gonna see her
car do what do you mean my car yo she's
my everything you run after her she's my
everything it's all [ __ ] day we go to
school go in the mornings I had a friend
hour and a half in the morning you know
I dress her I sit her down my I give her
a vitamin I got a hot chocolate milk my
wife you know does the brushing the
teeth we brush a hair and five o'clock
when he takes my help me ask you guys I
had to talk to the other guy listen know
when you can hold some squeeze I jump in
the [ __ ] shower though you're on fire
you're kicking because it's wet on top
of [ __ ] sweat on top of sweat so when
you bring him to school at 9:00 they
stay outside and sweat for an hour then
they go inside they sit in the [ __ ]
air conditioner she's got curly [ __ ]
thick hair so that sweat sits in the
scalp then after lunch they run around
again and they go back in and she sweat
her cheeks are red and the [ __ ] head
and the sweat pukes in the head then she
lays down for two hours and they talk
about God they talk about animals where
the [ __ ] they talk about about 3:30 they
came out they're like savages again and
they're sweating - my wife and me pick
her up - five [ __ ] thirty understand
me and by that time we pick up there's
been four different cultures sweat on it
that have dried and sweat when she gets
in the car and gives me a kiss I smell
it she smells like [ __ ] dead salt
you understand me can I take a home when
she sits with me and when I hugged one
that came in and I smelled this shirt
and I go why do I smell so bad and it
was because when I was sitting next to
computer
I just taken a shower and the head was
over here a head I got a shad she stinks
like she [ __ ] terrible every day but
she's a kid she runs around they're
filthy they're [ __ ] filthy I love her
to death
it's got a little kick though when she
comes home from school that's all I'm
trying to say do you have one of those
things where it's like a mop onesie and
so she cleans the floor while she's
running around not really I'm not the
Communist activity listen man I the
worst thing ever is when I'm on the road
and people give me stuff and it gets
juggled sometimes people give me stuff
and it gets [ __ ] juggled and when I
was the st. Louis this dude Dan came up
to me the first the second night gave me
a little container they had a number in
there I took the number on I took the
note out I put the note in my [ __ ]
wallet and I forgot about that I had
that [ __ ] hidden in there and
the other dad thought I misplaced made
the M card and I went looking in the
wallet and I read this note from this
guy and I kind of got sad because he
said he was in bad shape and he wanted
to sit with me for an hour but I bought
and I found I left st. Louis the second
week in July I just found the [ __ ]
thing last week so Dan if you listen you
know I love you and I'll be in touch of
you minutes with Marc Marco I love you
Joe Cunningham kicking wing Mick silico
Eric London Jimmy James more Gilpin and
Ryan mark Gilpin and Ryan the quality
you know I love you [ __ ]
I'm very sorry about the Borgata is sold
out but I'll be back [ __ ]
[ __ ] Gotham November 2nd week go to
Gotham calm New York City whatever the
[ __ ] it is for details you guys got a
lot of time sorry about that I really
didn't think that tickets would go that
fast so thank you for the love and
support you people [ __ ] aces are you
gonna play anything in Atlantic City did
you go as a kid you always talked about
people going I went to Atlantic City
they'll be strictly Alistair you may be
three times and I think one time I
played slots and I ain't crab legs one
time I went down there to see a concert
maybe I don't [ __ ] know I've been to
Atlantic City three times I know nothing
about I can lie to you and I know this
for a famous for sandwich place in
Philly or a famous hamburger place if I
got time I go with C what the [ __ ] they
thought I got kicked out of a pool party
for having a hat in Atlantic City why do
they look it's like a dress code like no
hat no flip no flip-flops and Harris
okay did you have like a baseball hat
yeah oh you thought you liked [ __ ]
rapper G you don't think girls are good
in baseball hats really good stop no
have you seen that [ __ ] chick that's
driving with her sister in the back of
the club if your sister dies I don't
like watching that stuff I can't ever
see the video of it it's been going
around in the prosecutor did you see
yeah I saw it
she's in the car acting like Johnny I
never understood that behavior
I never understood that behavior unless
you're an actual rapper that's making
millions of [ __ ] dollars then you can
do all this [ __ ] [ __ ] with hats on
backwards inside that I want to [ __ ]
see it you got to see when you fly from
anywhere the hell away when you fly from
anywhere like when you
well and say you spend the weekend in
Orlando Florida you fly from LAX to
Orlando Florida you land you get off the
plane you go do your thing for three
days when you get back to Orlando on
Sunday to fly back look at the people as
you approach the terminal of the people
will your flight is to go in town I look
around at the people how they changed
for the rest of the people in the
airport also you see more woman with
yoga pants on
one with hot pants and heels walking
Lloyd 6:00 in the morning what is all
this drama I'm doing a [ __ ] guitar
don't do that come on a plane with a
guitar you drive me [ __ ] crazy
they come on with the [ __ ] guitar and
it skateboard you drive me you did you
drive me [ __ ] crazy
you drive me [ __ ] crazy with those
[ __ ] guitars like really pack that
[ __ ] with [ __ ] luggage
what does I could talking to do like all
that [ __ ] drives me crazy but those are
the people you know once you start
seeing service dogs you know you know
you're taking a flight back to Los
Angeles ekits it's really sad I'm
leaving my [ __ ] boy this is [ __ ] it's
funny when though I always make a joke
because you used to live in Florida yeah
I always make a joke when I went to
visit my dad because when all the fights
to Fort Lauderdale like you know like
they had like most like to have like one
or two people with a wheelchair that
flat has like 30 people with wheelchairs
on the front and I I made a joke to the
stewards is that it's all all Jewish
people have it have to Sam which is in
every single row like it's but it's
funny like it was there for those areas
so I'm sure it happens everywhere maybe
like for LA I'm sure it's weird going on
the way back it's people would just
completely fake right completely
different you see Gugu looking dudes and
to take a shower the hair is extra
[ __ ] up to let you know they don't
care
you know you get women dressed to the
nines you get black dudes that look like
they're on
coverage Jet magazine and you know what
at the end of the day there often than
wrote dirty to a so all that [ __ ]
costume to sit in the back of the
[ __ ] play I could see if you were
flying first-class and you think you're
[ __ ] Johnny doo-wop you get the
[ __ ] Johnny boy in yon hat and you
sit down with you [ __ ] Chinese
girlfriend with the lake I had on his
[ __ ] I understand if you never sit in
[ __ ] first class not that I fly first
class I'm just saying
but for that [ __ ] get up if you're
not flying in first class why do you
have that costume why the [ __ ] do you
have that outfit on to do what
just put jeans on and sneakers and a
[ __ ] t-shirt and be yourself that's
what drives me [ __ ] crazy so I'm not
saying I don't like you and I just like
to accessorize I'm not trying to be one
of those people with the hats on hanging
out with the people with the guitars on
the airplane yeah [ __ ] guitars an
airplane like yeah you're the rush you
need to play sometimes you never know
what's that well they actually have
Hadley stories of like United or
whatever breaking really expensive
guitars it's not purpose if I was done I
break those guitar to one by one I'd be
breaking those guitars so many things
you need to cut the strings with the
[ __ ] thing but you know what I'm
lying to you because if you check it I'm
cool with you some people that bring the
[ __ ] thing on the plane like thinking
a bus stop and so on like somebody on
the planes I know we didn't know you
have a guitar can you sing us a song
somebody's gonna have a panic attack on
the plane like hey is there anybody who
could sing a song to soothe this woman
what the [ __ ] about to vomit to start
this [ __ ] so are you moving out of Miami
full-time that's it you're gonna be out
here I knew [ __ ] starvin gonna give
Lucy Lou a run Tom I was Lucy Lou
standin when um when she started her
show elementary in Miami in New York and
there was she sweet to you she was cool
she's she was like really nice like she
talked to everybody on set you
like one guy got like a black eye for
something and she he came to work on
Monday and she was like she was like
what happened to you you know she was
concerned about him she was nice
you tell her you willing to be a bad
[ __ ] in knocking off her number-one
spot take up posted yeah we had we had
that staring contest did you really know
you the baddest [ __ ] out there right
now sounds like you're promoting a UFC
fight these [ __ ] don't know you
don't say Lucy lose a battle good what
couldn't pay me to go to UFC fight I
don't want you to know that you're safer
I don't give a [ __ ] of you one of that
you know uncle Joey who wants to take it
to a USC if I do not like that stuff at
all I just don't like fighting then
don't go yeah don't watch it even if
it's like set up and they're getting
paid for it it's still violent and you
know it's startling I understand you
don't like to see people get bunch of
that yeah you just said earlier that you
like seen street fights and a guy beat
up his chick and choked around with a
[ __ ] shirt off no he wasn't being
violent she they were just drunk and
high and [ __ ] up they were just
screaming just running through the
street I was like yo man you're lucky
you didn't just get hit by a car so you
see is something you don't like the EOC
rephrases it's that the violence and
they punch each other and just hit your
stomach a different way yeah exactly
yeah I know a lot of people that feel
that way they don't yeah you know when
you grow up with violence in your home
it's like it's traumatizing for you so
it's not you it's not entertaining for
me to watch that did they beat you at
the church yeah you know but not at the
church is like in my house oh hey you
both of them um my brother your brother
you should walk in there yeah you
thought it with him sorry what do you
think no no did you forgive
no I found a therapist who told me that
I don't have to forgive him so you pay a
dude to say what do you think yeah
forgive them no yeah yeah and then you
just keep paying people till you find
that person charged me a week to four
I'll give you a ten package you don't
know how much do they charge I'm
thinking about doing it but I just I
used to want a therapist there um I see
her when I need a tune-up
do you are you happier yeah are your
medication no you straight up James
start this star the star medication yeah
are you happy with how long have you
been in therapy is a total um probably
like two years okay
that's word for you makes you feel
better yeah yeah I think it's helped
does it is it effective for you stand up
yeah good claim my little bit do you
meditate you also go to yoga I go to
yoga I meditate okay yeah a little bit
why did you take the medication to stop
hearing the voices what medication the
one that you told me you were taking me
cuz you hearing voices from Vietnam no I
do think I just think these stars with
you okay yeah that's good that this you
know man like marijuana marijuana is the
best medication because it just calms
you down you know when I got locked up
dad therapist in there I used them as an
hour of entertainment myself I really
it's really embarrassing do you do the
kind where like you'd totally actually
like tell stories like no it was like a
man's group that you went on Wednesday
night
you're talking a group grope some people
spoke about their beefs in the prison
some people spoke about their
expectations when they got out of prison
and [ __ ] like that you know and I went
to a couple of those I don't know I felt
like I was giving them 50% of what I'm
supposed to give them and then when I
got out of prison at the halfway house
they had a dude you had in-house therapy
and you're trying to pay for one session
a month and the guy's name was how each
well and he was cool as [ __ ] and to make
things even better I was tight with his
brother so his brother worked at me on
the sly and I would go see this brother
you always find the Jews and yeah I
loved and at first it was weird because
at first I used them as a hand job
because this state wanted me to do it so
I just found him a [ __ ] you know as I am
but then I came up positive one time for
cocaine and they they're gonna put me in
jail or I got a scratch another did you
just shave them no it's been years since
I seen that's scary because everyone's
someone you put a pair jeans on you
leave brush even saying I watched it
like four times today I went I was hours
I pick about four shots you're the
reason we're in a drought I think a
shower this morning then when I got back
- you did - I took a shower and I went
to pick up mercy and we ran around and
the shirt just stunk
I know if it was body yard I had a shirt
that something happened to it you gonna
pick up a shirt you put on and while
you're in the car you like something
right good fart or something happened to
ice like I wanted to arrest or I forget
like farts trapped in your blanket all
the time when you lift it up you smell
the fart even if you didn't fart for the
past
[Laughter]
that's terrible astok you know that
wasn't fun I sweet I love farting yeah
it's 2017 you don't believe that girls
fart I believe what's the budget time
for change
and what is the gambling Woods I'm not
sure I have I have a we'll see how how I
do the first night I think I just wanna
make one bit on the UFC and then I'm
deciding and I know your thoughts
already but I'm deciding if I want to
make it small Mayweather McGregor bent
just to see the whole thing
what you just deal with the betting
front you don't worry about me Gregg
away whether something might happen then
you can bet that online worry about the
move and funny look at the end of cards
look at the middle card look at what the
money is on the [ __ ] card but most
importantly look at the weigh-in okay
make sure at 3:30 on give a [ __ ] what
Paul SSI the total [ __ ] library look
what day it's probably gonna be Friday
it's [ __ ] sold out it's sold out I'll
just make sure Friday at 3:30
you don't Paula take a [ __ ] hike and
you go to the sports book and watch the
weigh-in
okay and watch the way in the top five
are you dating a Polish no her name is
Paula and see what how they looked at
the thing and you'll see one whole way
about the two fights don't ever worry
about the two main card phone that's
wrong then it doesn't matter what you
want to bet you're in Julian in it to
make money betting is to serve you
better Julie but you don't know nothing
way you get born to death you know
you've been giving those casinos money I
think you don't go back to Johnny
durante listen to me
look at me listen to me
make a smart bet make one move and get
the [ __ ] out of it you never look at the
in cycling it's like a Monday Night
Football game if you better money left
foot ball game you're a sucker that's
six o'clock America game you're a sucker
those of people who are desperate
because they lost all weekend a football
if you bet that NBC game that game the
fix is already [ __ ] him before you
playing guess what it's gonna be against
you as usual you're not gonna bail on
the parlay the usual to sinking the
eternal flames of hell and you're out
one Savior Monday night and guess what
Monday night's about putting the
blowtorch in your balls and killing you
for six [ __ ] months how do I know
this again the reason why I don't buy a
BMW is because I so cause the reason why
I don't gamble is because I worked for a
sports betting service and I learned the
one thing you make the same amount of
money man Mayweather
I guess my Gregor has or Birds faith I
guess New Mexico State really doesn't
matter you just want a better to tell
your friends how [ __ ] cool you are if
you're looking to make money you're
looking to make money that's true but if
there's no but lay your BTL just get the
tattoo on your [ __ ] shoulder what's
that mean going to lose you're not gonna
beat the books if you hit the books four
times E and you go three and one chance
of being ripped to net winners so if you
put a $3,000 you put a two thousand
dollar bet four times a year and you go
three and one that means you won $4,000
for the [ __ ] hit right as people have
to work all year for that you know why
cuz you're better smart you're not
better be nobody's [ __ ] chillin I'm
also not betting that high our mouth
doesn't really matter
then why then why even make the move to
waste your time well the city did about
25 bucks and then why make the move if
you're gonna make them moving yeah but
make the [ __ ] move guy well I used to
gamble uh-oh I think I robbed gas
stations why did I rob [ __ ] jewelry
store I think I did all those horrible
things over the years because I bet when
you gonna go go well then you're gonna
go go I had the same problem you had I
couldn't pick a winner but guess what
over the years I've learned how again
right now it's what I always leave with
three or four hours and for Diaz I made
money a couple fights last Chad made
money and nobody knew and you make a
good point I'll definitely look at the
undercard bunny oh yeah I can't doesn't
really matter what or who you want to do
you're in business to do one thing when
you gamble and that business is make
money that's true
oh you little [ __ ] trees of my
favorite he's from Boston it all goes
out the window and gamming especially
for sports that's why they tell you
never to bank that's your home team
never been against that's rule number
one cuz you always going to lose
especially no this anyway you live it
you can bet New England just don't bet
the Rams but it's hard for me I'm like I
don't know if you never bet against the
Red Sox that's the issue so that I'm
gonna stay away from that game it's
probably another game like just because
you're a [ __ ] Red Sox fan doesn't mean
you have to bet them late yeah exactly
six baseball games you never bet what
you just [ __ ] say your home team
because you been emotionally you're in
this business to make money that's why I
wasn't gonna gambling but as I got older
I knew how to make moves right you learn
how to go it doesn't there's 17 weeks in
a football season right yes if you can
win three times for two thousand of
[ __ ] time which you could do and
stuff
let me play a three team partly for two
teams for three dollars of preaching and
win dick that right and the lapel if you
win thinking they're gonna get you later
on you want to bets more in and out
there are
you always look at next week like when
you bet it like right now tomorrow I
want a best football okay look at that's
the cool this week I look at the games
but I also look at next week where they
gonna be and you always gotta ask
yourself and they lose two in a row
or will the overlooked the Super Bowl
last year New England okay so every
season will be watching the England from
week one that's the heavier NFL game
right you either hate Brady you don't
want anybody everybody gets the right
right so what do you do you stay away
from brainy and New England and those
are the games that you make money you
know you'll make money yeah let's look
at the [ __ ] card for the UFC okay
let's see if there's anything that just
stands out with the story
like those shorts that you wore these
are the only shorts that I've worn on
your show I know the best one is this
[ __ ] yeah why'd you cut them back oh why
do you have a little skirt covers the
back get ahold you muffle is that know
that's how these shorts come they come
with shorts or than that yeah sweatshirt
with like strings nice you know here I
was thinking that you were trying to be
[ __ ] stylish I think you just came
from the Soundgarden console rest in
peace I saw he's gonna try to be a
genius and I bet what they're all gonna
try the bet [ __ ] John Cormier John
okay now who else you got Laura Cerrone
and you gotta obey Maya Woodley Maya and
you got fabric Evan cyborg avenger'
which that just I don't know what can
happen that one scares me in that I
don't know you're not gonna make money
of your bedside boy right what's uh
what's the FX card see the one I like on
the FX card is the feeling one only
because and this is I've become a big
fan of your I favor on Instagram and his
team has gone on like an incredible run
his team and he's part of that team
alpha male who's we framed see it's it's
someone Qatar he has it he had
and I actually looked at this earlier
he's had a decent amount of fights but I
don't think he's been in the UFC before
oh that's not going to have a big show
so I think I think Calvin KTAR photo
shine because I don't think he's been on
the UFC before picture first time right
probably oh that's exciting everybody is
like googling him to see what you see
like right there google him like right
there nothing really comes out then I
want to bet on this card really like
nothing I can't I can't see the lawless
aroni fight back you going yeah that's
all right
is it Lola coming off a knockout they're
okay they're both coming off of losses
right they're both coming off our bosses
yeah this is a weird fight then you have
I don't know manner what guys supposed
to be pretty good eyesight what was he
fighting
ASDA mirror quick picture there Vulcan I
think I've seen him fight before
Switzerland 230 oh no these people see
what number is he what number see he is
number 5 and Jimmy mano 1 3 my new one
you know I forget this may be the guy
with the huh I don't [ __ ] know yet
nothing jumps out at me Demian Maia
wooly I could go either way
really I mean no way man even though how
on the tear that no disrespect to
Woodley with the tear that my husband
what do you think why will we can knock
him the [ __ ] the hell that's also very
true and I've heard will these a really
great wrestler he's a great wrestler you
know click on there's your collar you
know I don't really guys out on no stats
and stuff like that don't be angry with
me I don't know what this pedigree is
I'm very very sorry he's a pretty good
here's a better takedown defendant than
- I think he was a wrestling college or
something he's always the champ he's not
yeah hi guys nothing screams out of me
maybe I'll feel different on Saturday
just don't bet to bet me always remember
don't bet as you feel like you got a gun
too yet right you don't feel strong
about anything
yeah John Jones oh yeah go either way
oh I don't know I have a really strong
feeling that corneas gonna win I don't
know and-and-and-and Jones is a monster
and amazing but everything that I keep
watching this week all the interviews I
just like what Cormier saying I just
like the work he's putting in I like
that he's honest about about the the his
Ellison did the podcast with him man
Sarah and Jim Norton the UFC one and he
was very honest about what he thought
his shirt coming for her and that's the
one thing I don't really hear from John
Jones I he's just a little bit like just
to be a very honest it just seems like
if you look at other stories happening
you can I could just see this playing
out with him losing just all the trash
he's talking and it just it's just I
could just see it as a movie playing out
like that oh thank God I don't have to
bet the [ __ ] thing or be involved
with it I wish you a lot of luck I'm
back on it I'm bettin it hopefully you
win money and bring me back my fake from
three years ago
besides that esta cool I'm happy around
the road I want people to watch your
[ __ ] show cause you're talented woman
you're a [ __ ] savage you got some nice
shorts on tonight thank you well you had
it from here
I'm going to I might stop at Hooters
what's going on the hole is they do come
Wednesdays or show have you been there
before yeah
is it cool it's cool they good people
yeah who those um Stephen Stephen
Holloman beautiful my love yeah thank
you for coming back on the show thank
you for having me I'm gonna be in
Sacramento August 10th
laughs unlimited okay make sure you
[ __ ] in the church go down and
see has to cocoa and [ __ ] and tell them
the church sent you I'm happy you came
on as to cool number one
let me read off my sponsors and I'll get
you [ __ ] out of here I'm happy
you're here the month is over I guess
I'll see you [ __ ] Monday
morning we'll put
together one way or another but before
anything listen like I'm telling you -
she's a bat not - she's but days are
back and let's correct that portable
bird days they're not back they never be
around they've never been around that's
why - she's here to help you live better
live longer and walk around with a clean
little muffler you understand me because
trust me nobody but nobody walk to walk
around with a dirty muffler
hello tisha comm has devised a bore
little bird a that attaches right to
your toilet it takes 15 minutes right
lead 15 minutes 15 minutes to connect
bing bang boom and next thing you know
you live in Utopia you have no idea what
it is in a hot day when you've been
walking your feeders saw in these hurt
your hips feel a lot of place but you
got a poop you sit down your poop you
had a bad tuna fish sandwich it comes
out the wrong hole but guess who comes
for a rescue little sprinkling water
from that little bowl of a bidet into
your muffler and let me tell you
something your whole day will be
brightened it's like meditation yoga sex
cocaine ecstasy all in one if you
haven't had cold water sprinkled into
your [ __ ] and don't sit on those
things if you get I cuz next thing you
know you think you got two midgets
anymore just spitting up into you
[ __ ] it's that type act to see that's
when hello she does number two they
avoid different diseases for you say
hello say goodbye the swamp-ass say
goodbye the hemorrhoids and sending up
goodbye to just all I read ain't junk
that just hangs out down there sometimes
you miss a spot you know swimming yet
you walk around that spot ferments and
it sits in its and it collects other
particles as it goes out and that
creates [ __ ] stink cast and you can't
figure it out because you wipe your
muffler and it's clean but that little
stink button it's still in the corner
wasn't me yeah so who's gonna lick your
balls like nobody understand me that's
why you gotta have a portable bidet
that's where how old til she comes in
plus they got a 90-day guarantee all the
[ __ ] up like that
go to hell moto she calm right
now impressive Hildur calm /search boom
and get 10% off you understand me you
know why I'm uncle Joey sent you and
just right quickly
I don't think we've talked too much
about the portability I think we should
you're it's very doable if you wanted to
have one set up at the office if you
have your own bathroom at the office or
even maybe talk to your the office
manager he's saying that I can think I'm
on the road to install them and had no
problem for the weekend okay with a
portable birthday so I think I'm gonna
give it a shot but give it a shot from
the house take it anyway
go - hello - chicom / church right now
and get 10% off delivered the house let
me tell you something do yourself a
favor get two of them you know I love
them that much one for the office
bathroom and one for the house and don't
forget it not only cleans your muffler
you can put your nutsack in there you
don't saying I have your nutsack all
clean you'll put your monkey in there
and soak that before the [ __ ] guest
comes over hello - she calms last Church
10% number - monkey or your monkeys nest
that's right with all we all want to eat
better right everyone say better
everybody wants to eat healthier when it
comes to snack sometimes it feels like
the whole world delicious and then the
million calories are verses boring and
tasteless it feels like the whole world
is delicious and a billion calories
versus boring and just tasteless it
doesn't have to be that way up your
snack game with nature box nature box
has over a hundred snacks that taste
good and I'm actually better for you all
snacks are made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners nothing so
you can feel good about what you're
eating my favorites tellingly the
chocolate nom nom oh my god the cocoa
the lentils the holy great the whole
week vanilla our animal cookies the I
realized Yago cheddar trips those are
really good I like all of them there's a
sour cream and onion straws they got a
lot of great stuff a lot of good stays
and stuff you get home at night you have
the munch
you know what they have a reason
reclosable back so you eat only what you
need sometimes you don't need a whole
bag you just say to yourself you know
what I want to lose a little weight I'm
only gonna eat I'm gonna eat this in
three servings that's what nature bugs
does feed you're sure to find your new
snack obsession in nature box they add
new snacks every month
Capisce inspired by real customer
feedback the latest food trends and
professional chefs it's so simple is
what you do you're gonna go to nature
box calm
and nature box will deliver them right
to your door and they'll ring the bell
Bing bong
you open the door you got a nice look
back a snack and there's no risk all
right if you ever try a snack you don't
like don't eat it nature box replace it
for free there's what I'm gonna do and
right now you'll save even more nature
box is orphan the Church of what's
happened now family three free snacks
with your first order
when you go to nature box calm
that's nature box calm
for three free snacks with your first
order that's nature box.com slash Joey
listen give nature box a world they're
the most healthiest quality snacks
you're eating years and like I said
having got a little disposable reusable
bag you don't want to eat the whole bag
you just saving for later go to nature
box.com slash Joey and get your three
free snacks
I want to thank Khushi I want to thank
Nation box I want to take on it I want
to take my beautiful a little sweetheart
in we came on tonight Esther ku and one
thing my main man Lisa I yet I want you
guys know Matt the ball god I'm so not
I'm sorry but I'll see you guys the
following week August fit at the ice
house for working out with uncle Joey on
the side of him 15 bucks all right you
know I love you [ __ ] have a
great weekend stay black be safe
you
you